this is completely crazy yeah this is a
big game for vaccine like g4 I love it I
know that it probably doesn't work but I
love it f3 just good you have to play a
three and open up the Queen to guard all
the squares them what a fine now we can
take with Chet but it doesn't matter the
Queen still responds with chef that was
the whole point of the sack everyone
just take on that big FA and that's
Maxime just resigned before even waiting
for wayy to figure it out I wanted it so
bad and he did it we're ready to roll
here with the speed chess championship
let's talk about who our players are
today we've got Maxine Bosh Ayla Gravas
Wei Yi the second player from China and
back-to-back days will we have another
one move on it would take an upset in
the 15 over to order so it would it
would be it would be a big one if if way
you could pull this off Maxine Bosh Ayla
Grove has an SCC record of three and
three with his only three losses in
history coming to Hikaru Nakamura so
what would happen if Maxime could ever
get by hick or Nakamura well he might
win himself his first ever speed chess
championship as we look at the
predictions obviously it's it's there
Maxine was clearly the favorite there at
58% but we're gonna roll through here to
the format remind you guys that it's the
same show you've been watching now for a
few years it's the most exciting
action-packed format that you could ever
ask for
with 90 minutes of 5-1 60 minutes of 3-1
and then 30
it's a bullet and we've got an
interesting daily question we'll get to
in a second so I'm a foreshadow that and
talk about maybe another way that we're
considering making the format even more
exciting and interesting the bracket is
obviously single elimination and the
winner moves on what are they playing
for well it's cash money homie and a lot
of it so we've got 16 grand up in the
first round that's a thousand dollars to
the winner and then another $1,000 split
by win percentage one of the things we
try to do in the format to encourage
that the players are always playing
fighting chess cuz every game counts for
at least a little bit of something
obviously moving on is the much bigger
prize though as less players stay around
the prizes continue to just get bigger
and bigger all the way to two players
competing for 10 grand in our final
three our blitz match coming up later
this year how were the players seated a
lot of people ask that as we look at it
well they were seated by feet a ratings
as of the July supplement that's how we
see to the 2 through 12 pairings and
then we seeded our qualifiers
essentially based on the order in which
they got themselves into the event we've
got the women's speech Chess
Championship winner actually throwing
down tomorrow in the third team seed
versus yonder pom neo she and our
Invitational qualifier the 14th seed the
junior speech has championship winner
kind of a funny thing that we have Wei
Yi a guy that was invited into our main
event last year
is it now had to qualify his way in but
he did so so as much as as we said and
we take a look at the bracket here that
Maxime is a big favorite it's also I
think it could be fair to say that he
probably didn't want to face a guy like
Wei Yi in the first round this is a guy
that is obviously the top junior in the
world but as we said played in the SEC
last year and along with a guy like ting
Li Ren who won last night for those of
you who watched it considered maybe one
of China's greatest hopes for an
eventual World Chess Championship title
so let's take a look at what our stats
say in regards to who has the best
chances here the 58 percent I mentioned
earlier is is really not as high as I
would put it in terms of how I look at
these two players because of Max seams
experience on our server and because of
his I guess blitz and bullet status that
I
I feel is a notch above way Yee but also
if you just consider the chest the
pound-for-pound action where you've been
above 27 40 so so I can see that so
let's let's bring on the players now and
and get ready here and a few moments for
the games to begin I'm flying solo this
morning and if you're with me and a
little bit frustrated about that I
apologize but you can get at me on
Twitter as you see and let me know your
feelings about the commentary today
we've got our players as I said ready to
roll the man from France the Frenchman
with three names Maxine Bosch say the
Groth versus Grandmaster Wei Yi and I'm
pretty excited pretty pumped chances I
may be joined by a co-host in the later
segments of this a match today but right
now it's just met one man one desire and
one opportunity to provide some great
chess commentary as the games get
rolling and on that note they actually
have begun and the timer has started
ticking down maybe Maxime not aware that
he's on the clock nope he was he was
just double-checking that he remembered
how the chess pieces moved that happens
sometimes to 2800 s they just forget how
to play I hear anyway but let's remind
everybody as the show gets underway here
we have a Sicilian of what our daily
question is if that's okay because we
want to remind you that you can get
involved on social media and today are
our question is isn't an interesting one
because it relates to the format we've
been wondering what are some ways we can
continue to not only add excitement but
make every game count even more one way
might be to dismiss draws in terms of
their total score and have not only that
those points but actually that money
carryover into a future game so that
would make the game following it perhaps
worth double or even triple if they
continue to draw and something that
might be interesting to consider if if
you're looking for even more fighting
chess so curious on your thoughts on
this fans let us know on social media
use the hashtag speed chess you can hold
your mouse over the twitch extension the
twitch player if you're happen to be
viewing on Twitch and then vote directly
there but alright we're gonna dive into
commentary here I can't wait to do it
I'm pretty excited to see what these
guys got for us so we had a Sicilian if
we analyze and back this thing up we had
a Rasul mo what seems to be super in
vogue these days
he's Bishop to b5 development and after
Bishop d7 takes and then c4 what you
have is a mirach C buying structure
where two differences both positive and
negative for both sides white won't have
the bad bishop kind of locked in the
side the light squares and the pawn
structure there but black also normally
struggling for space has gotten rid of
one of those pieces which means blacks
development is a little bit accelerated
and the pieces aren't wrestling each
other for so many squares so that's
that's kind of a storyline of this
particular pawn structure as we reach
the middle game again where white
normally having this light square Bishop
is kind of kind of a bad piece although
also important in some ways to hold the
structure together black normally having
his light square bishop normally sits on
d7 which again just kind of makes the
pieces a little bit a little bit cramped
so the fact that black gets rook c8 so
quickly the c4 pawn is potentially more
of a target without the bishop being
here so its pros and cons for both in
this particular transition so rook c8
met by b3 interesting move here and I
think that one of the key ideas might be
that black is gonna try to move this
knight from c6 and strive for either b5
or in some cases if you can organize it
eventually d5 and right as I was
highlighting that maxime is now gonna
have to deal with the movie 6 which kind
of has the intention to prepare this and
one of the reasons you go for that in a
Sicilian is because white has the more
dominant space more dominant pawn
structure if you can't change that if
you can break through in the center and
say equalize that factor very often
black is taking care of all of his
issues and sometimes the pieces that are
sort of hidden over here become ninjas
and and sort of pounce on the on the
center and then come to life so the
double-edged nosov of e6 I think double
edged Ness is a word is it too early to
use words like double-edged tunas I hope
not but II sixth is weakening the D pawn
right so once you commit this you can't
really go back so we see Maxine playing
92 and he's gonna try to punish way you
for that he's opening the D file hitting
the d6 pawn and trying to really put the
clamps on the d5 breakthrough saying
you're not not today junior not not
today Junior which by the way is an
appropriate reference given
the way he qualified his way in to this
event via the junior speeches
championship so not today junior it's a
real thing let's remind everybody who he
is he may have qualified his way in but
he's also number three in China so he's
one of the top players in the world
known as lovei on chess calm
I like that username maybe not as much
as chefs house from last night's match
with ding li Ren but I do I do enjoy the
love a user name he's number three as we
said in China top five in China in all
the major categories classical rapid and
blitz so this guy is it's pretty good
what's Maxime eating that's a good
question but who is Maxime vache the
graph that's at least something we can
answer he's chewing on what I'm gonna
guess is almonds that's his brain food
of choice but he's also number one in
France and both classical rapid and
blitz all three categories he's also the
number one rapid player in the world
right now which is not not an easy feat
we've been following this guy pretty
much all year as he's just continued to
perform at the highest level so exciting
stuff it's White Way he has his work cut
out for him and as we go back to the
live position here
I wonder if Bishop e6 isn't just gonna
pick up the D pond so what happened in
this transition over the last couple
moves as we got to know them black
strive for b5 and this is what I
foreshadowed this is the common
structural idea black has to make a
breakthrough just look at the position
everyone when White has much more space
and a whole lot of pieces that know how
to use it you have to change that
structure if you can't wrestle your way
to wrestle your way into an equal fight
for squares so b5 along with d5
are the ways you try to change that
structure but here doing so despite the
fact that it comes with a tempo on the
Queen and the end of the line it opens
up the square b6 and as we see where ye
kind of go into the think tank there I'm
gonna guess maybe he just blundered that
pun because it doesn't make a lot of
sense if we now get to the live position
where Maxime just grabbed it looks to me
like he's she's gonna be up a pond and
and loving it right but up up up upon
and loving it that's the new theme song
we're gonna need to refill on the coffee
today for sure these jokes are already
falling flat so alright but he did he
won the pawn on d6 and that was the
double edge
risk of e6000 for that structural
breakthrough his black trying to get d5
but the you know strongest players in
the world can sometimes help those
planes backfire Black is getting some
compensation so let's hold the phone on
calling this one just yet if the rook
had come to see two you might get an
initiative the problem I think Maxime
house just rook d2 and and you got
nothing
so now way he's gonna have to think
about how do I take advantage of what
seems to be a temporary problem for
white right Knights retreated the bishop
and rook off place he goes for rook c2
but as I said rook d2 and the problem is
I'm not really seeing a follow up I
guess rook c8 makes the most sense for
Wei Yi keep the pressure yeah he does it
and now he can even trade and kind of
renew the threat by bringing the second
rook into situ but in the end he's down
a pawn and even as he goes for this line
I'm guessing white might have a way to
go for before man when I go solo I'm
able to predict moves even better I know
what's going on need to get these
grandmasters out of here apparently I'm
a stronger chess player if I just think
on my own so yeah this is the counter
play you get here comes rook c8 and if
you force bishop f8 there's Bishop h6
ideas the main point in the end though
is that black will have the move Knight
to d7 one of them anyway to guard f8 so
it's not just Red Rover
but there's other ideas like Bishop c5
in some positions where you can actually
take b4 and keep the pin and defend d2
is that what he has in mind look at this
at Bishop c5 and the knight has to come
to d7 and you gobble b4 I'm getting my
cake and eating it too so Maxine was
taking a think about whether he can get
away with this idea I guess one thing to
consider is whether but I can take but
then you take with the bishop and I'm
assuming that there's threats that are
problematic okay so no Maxime actually
decided that he couldn't get away with
it and played the move h3 a more
prophylactic approach only to play
Knight d4 more slowly and I think one of
the things he's saying about the
position is that black is still in a
bind despite the fact that he didn't
immediately execute a Bishop c5 idea but
I admit I'm wondering what
but what have happened there and I'm
thinking there may have been something
on on taking d2 but no I don't know if
you take f8 what's the deal right how do
you stop Bishop h6 checks okay not quite
sure what would have happened there
maxime up on the clock though so still
in a pretty pretty great position in
regards to get a full point here in the
first game but we'll I'll keep thinking
about the position in my brain so if I
get that blank look on my face it's not
a dancing monkey in my head it's
actually I'm just I'm curious I'm
wondering what it was on Bishop c5 that
I was missing but I'll figure it out
don't you worry I was just rook a 1
check in 90 okay now I'm gonna show him
back to the analysis board gotta show
what I figured out here's the deal I had
to solve it if Bishop c5 the problem was
check and then Knight d3 check okay that
was the problem there we go everything's
okay everyone crisis averted
we solved the tactic okay so the knight
comes to d3 anyway and that actually
makes sense as to why Maxime played Age
3 to begin with right needed to create
some space for his King and I want to
say that from a practical point of view
even if these guys will sometimes miss a
concrete knockout one of the things that
guys like Maxime I would say Hikaru
some of the best blitz and bullet
players in the world do is is they just
understand that the the moment of the
game as much as they do the need to find
the concrete answer like Maxime up on
time knows that he's in a great position
here he's controlling the tempo of the
game didn't need to go for something
crazy and that's why they always tend to
win in in games where you know it wasn't
necessarily a blowout but games where
they kind of outplay their opponent when
it matters most under time pressure
right as I'm saying now he's speaking of
Wei Yi holding his own in time pressure
look at this he's won the b-pawn and now
he can calculate ideas where he rushes
it even with white taking on e5 that's
gonna be an exciting finish here the
rook can come back to b8 and the knight
can come to d3 yeah he plays for OPA
first now you can play Knight d3 which
hits the bishop but then Bishop d4 and
black is kind of sitting pretty right
the bishop on d4 does a few things
everyone at guards the knight and helps
b2 oh wow
he's got something even stronger
he's just gonna go after d2 immediately
Wow look at way Yi holding his own and
if there's an upset in the air today
it's gonna it's gonna have to happen in
these time scrambles away you proves his
own not exactly sure why
super grandmaster video Gujarati is
disappointed at me it could be a number
of reasons my wife has a long list if
you'd like them but vid it if you want
to explain why your when Sony gia vid it
if you want to hop in the call and join
me for commentary you're invited buddy
okay so if you want to bring it with the
trash talk hop on the mic okay visit
you're welcome just reach out reach out
to my boy my boy Nick and you can be on
the call anytime in but thanks for being
here regardless of that and
congratulations by the way and playing
in the quarterfinals coming up October
four through six we have the Fisher
random world chess championship
quarterfinals and check out the players
there that is going to be some event I
don't even know what to say about how
excited I am for that event if you
didn't if he didn't could tell by the
way I said championship I was not
kidding about how excited I am for that
look at Maxine may be holding the draw
here though this is uh
this is gonna be interesting if he can
do it the night will come to f3 look at
that broke on h5 though dirty dog traps
him in a weird way okay he should be
able to draw now that being Maxine did
here's Widow time oh my gosh oh the
first full freak out of the day no he's
okay
oh man living on the increment living on
the edge it is gonna have to be a long
day for this guy some coffee is is
needed we have a peaceful ending to a
very back and forth Game one and and
there you go well VIN it I'll see you in
just a few moments haha let's go when my
son says haha let's go I say get in the
car and be quiet okay if you want to hop
on the stream you don't have to be quiet
but let's do it okay now we're back in
the night now this is gonna be an
interesting storyline to this match is
wayyy gonna challenge Maxine
night or if we back up and analyze let's
remind you everybody that Maxine voce
the Grove is known as the world's
leading expert in the sharpest Sicilian
and that is defined as the move a six
this is a night ourf Sicilian and he
knows how to use it
the point of a six obviously both
accelerated attacks on the queenside and
usually it supports a move like a five
and the be five square is not accessible
just the very very basic principles we
get e5 the night retreats this line with
the the fianchetto here on the kingside
is of one of the more positional
approaches white wants to eventually use
the d5 square and potentially transition
into a big pawn storm on the Queen side
and all and actually show that that's
happening on the board right now as we
speak right this night comes to d5 you
want to support it your positionally
saying yes you gain some time with e5
but that might be a pawn move you wish
you could come you can move backward if
you end up giving me full control over
the light squares and be positionally
worse to go with it
but black has the typical Sicilian
counter play right accelerated
compensation on the Queen side starting
with an open C file constant threats to
disrupt that grip on the center and when
that happens things like efore and d5
come under target so rook to see a plate
maybe wait now thinking hey did I just
really go into a night or four against
maxing vache de Graaf like what was I
thinking with that I don't even know but
I'm gonna I'm gonna figure out figure
out what what to do now the rook comes
to ca what are the right plans here for
white between d3 is a candidate move
this move over protects things like
efore and d5 connects the rooks and then
usually prepares a for but actually as I
look at in this position now I'm not
surprised a form is played the fact that
this Knight is already on d5 guarding b4
means that a4 can't be met by a strike
like this right why it'll just take the
pawn happily and that's kind of key
because one of the ways that white tries
to punish the knight ourf is to make
those pawns push even further right as
this structure opens up a6 is an obvious
target as soon as the a file is open for
business and white also has the the two
pawn majority advantage which if you let
let these pawns get
they want to be it'll be things like c4
and b4 and a big Center to go with the
bishop pair but Maxime knows this line
well you don't just give up your Yorkie
LightSquared Bishop and weakened a6
unless you have a direct follow-up I'm
gonna guess the main idea is that if
Queen takes we have rook takes c2 and if
pawn takes a couple things one of them
being that you've actually changed the
pawn structure in a typical way to give
yourself an attack on the King side here
you also have Queen to c7 immediately if
you want to hit C to slide to b7 hit b2
and then eventually go back for the idea
of been talking about it's one of the
reasons you take on d5 to change that
structure so that f5 is eventually an
effective idea we see that maxime
immediately responded with the move a5
that's the way he chooses to defend the
pawn where Yi plays the move c3 and I'm
guessing f5 come soon no Knight b6 oh
that's a nice tactic if you take a 5 we
have nice c4 a little bit of a fork do a
little dance make a little fork get down
tonight and you don't want to part with
the dark square bishop maxime just has
such a good feel for these positions
it's seriously fascinating because I
feel like I would take so much time
before making a choice to give up my
light square bishop here kind of a
catalyst if you will to the entire
structure but he does it so quickly and
just knows that the dynamics here are
gonna be okay for him because if you
can't take a 5 black is gonna play a 4
next and then black is kind of holding
on to everything on the Queen side along
with moves like Knight c4 just wow way
he's calling his bluff
maxime gave a little bit of a Hikaru
Nakamura number 13 shrug they're not
quite the full look up at the ceiling
but a bit of a head tilt he gets Knight
c4 as we said the fork commences
he wants the pawn though impressive well
Yi's getting greedy
I appreciate your username dr. ginger
Vitus
first of all let's fight ginger Vitus
together right I assume that's why you
have that username not to troll but to
be a pillar of light thanks for being
here
also cheese appreciate the chess TV chat
so many of our regulars we've got max we
got we got Stephie typewriter I call him
the oh geez of the chess TV chat before
the emotes were even cool to use on
chess TV though those those peeps were
hanging out being strong so alright rook
b8 is played black wants to get get
happy on the B file before just settling
on the obstacle Bishop ending here wow
look at this
I'm being visited by an angel with
coffee thank you sir I think he feels
bad for me today I'm flying solo he's
like yeah welcome to my world Dani all
the work I do is solo okay I've got
everything I could ever need here
including some Arizona tea which is
light and refreshing alright okay Maxime
Glazebrook v8 Queen b3 and he's gonna
continue to bring the pressure on the B
file with Queen c7 he wants to exchange
and then bring another rook into the
game yeah the product placement if only
we got paid for product placement that's
why nobody sponsors our shows they're
like learning you you guys already get
all the free product placement we could
ever ask for
so you know alright he eventually
exchanges he's going after e3 the thing
about the position for black is despite
being down a pawn if you're evaluating
it objectively as far as blacks goals at
the highest level of chess blacks
probably Justin totally fine shape to
hold a draw in this game so again the
point is if as much as we talked about
the knight or being max seems expertise
remember when 27 50s go at it black
isn't usually more ambitious than
thinking he should get a draw with his
approach and so this is one that he has
a theoretically kind of prepared idea
that he knows he can go for this even
with the the fork that only led to an
opposite code Bishop ending
I'm guessing I'm gonna guess that Maxime
still feels like he's in plenty plenty
good shape to hold this position not
just because he's relaxing they're
probably trying to work out that giant
chess injury that occurred for him when
I almost beat him a couple weeks ago in
st. Louis I want to talk about it okay h
5 h 4 you can relocate the Bishop to c5
where it's it's pretty and and yet to
look out I mean at some point the dark
squares on the Kings side could be weak
right I'm not just thinking of some sort
of you know fantasy of a checkmate
attack where the Queen and Bishop work
together but even in an endgame these
pawns stuck on these squares could be
targets so you got to watch out for that
rook a6 is he just laughing in the face
of danger in terms of rook b5 and rook
e8 I guess he was probably saying
something like you trade in the end of
these lines you uh you may regret it
right so came g7 Bishop f1 I don't know
how ambitious black can be here right if
black starts to do things like f5 the
open seventh rank likely backfires moves
like rook c6 are coming so he finally
trades on b5 I'm still guessing rook b8
comes now the B to pawn falls with check
um maxime feeling it feeling the dance
feeling the moves oh when he sees Bishop
c1 not sure way you saw this idea if he
plays before c3 falls so he goes for it
what's he saying he's saying you show me
mine I show you yours rook to c6 in erm
is Oh hmm he's gonna eventually take on
d6 the problem is b4 falls and with it
comes the second ring yeah he's trying
to bail out now Queen d3 is a bail out
movie saying I I want to I want the end
game now I'm nervous
okay Jake's Bishop takes a3 Bishop g2
but now black can play rook b2 okay or
brook b3 both moves unleash the bishop
that was the point to guard e6 you can
put the Bishop on c5 try to us five
squares like f2 and don't oh my gosh you
need look wait did love I just resign
there I have no idea I'm just gonna back
up and take a look he resigned in the
position is it cuz he just knew he was
gonna get flagged was he just frustrated
with the fact that he went from up upon
to down upon I mean if you look at the
obstacle Bishop ending black holds all
the cards right with a dominant rook and
Bishop with more targets to come but
okay resigning is is another order
though resigning is a whole nother level
of being frustrated right that's my
level of depression the kind you seek
help for so I don't even know what's
going on with him resigning this quickly
f5 and f4 is coming for black and so
make no mistake I think that black is
better but I'm a little shocked by that
as we see the next game rolling Mac
seemed not so shocked he's uh yeah
sometimes you get real on this show
especially when Dan flies solo that's
why we keep him keep him away from those
shows so yeah we we have an a Sicilian
again this time efore from Maxime not
quite the night off
I wonder what Maxime strength would be
if he ever fully focused on chess I mean
is this guy stopped fidgeting since we
went live everyone I'm gonna talk to him
about it afterwards get ready for a fun
interview because Maxime talks way too
much trash for his own good alright well
we've got a Sicilian here and we'll see
how way you wants to take an approach to
a typical ala pin structure where white
tries to get the center and keep it and
what we mean by that I talk about this a
lot and if you're ever looking for these
types of events to maybe be suggestions
for you in terms of how to map your own
repertoire I know my my goal is often to
just try to lecture on what I think
to be educational for the viewer sorry
I'm a teacher at heart but but it really
is true that every one of these
approaches they take is its sound and
played for a reason and so if you're
looking for suggestions and maybe you
don't like the sharpest variations of
the open sicilians that occur with
things like d4 you see a lot of these
players playing the anti Sicilians now
we've seen Bishop e5 twice here today by
Maxine but here we have a slightly
different approach from Wei Yi 97
instead of the move Bishop d7 that was
played in game 1 and that leads to an
Allen pin structure was c3 where what
White's saying is look yeah I want d4
and I want to have more control over
this critical square but I also don't
want to give you the two pawns versus
one a long-term positional advantage so
instead I play c3 to make sure that when
I do get d4 I'm gonna take back with the
pawn and be super happy here
so Bishop to d3 is retreated with the
sole purpose of getting that big Center
before you get d4 eventually it happens
and this is actually an instructor point
to you because if white achieves this
goal excuse me of the big Center it's
usually not in blacks interest to take
it because that frees up the c3 square
for the knight and then allows the big
Center to continue to be used so if if
the alop in let's say philosophy is
executed often black will just maintain
the tension rather than capture which is
what he does here and only take after a
move like Knight B to d2 because once
the knight is no longer threatening to
take the most logical development Square
at that point you can trade and try to
be a little more active in the center
because you're not worried about white
having this sort of dream position you
teach your students about right 9 F 1
and and again on that note but cuz
Maxime lacks the knight on the natural
square look what way he's doing he's
able to strike with d5 and then play the
knight into E for something that happens
again because white lacks this knight on
c3 so good stuff Bishop d3 played by
Maxime I think it's a structure that
still has a tiny edge for white just
based on a space advantage and a bad
French Bishop and it's one of those
things where just suddenly you're
analyzing and a man appears next to you
that you look for help and you've been
saved and I'm not even sure he can hear
me
let's just keep talking as if he's not
here and video Gujarati will be joining
us in just a moment live from his
beehive honeycomb behind him I'm not
sure what's going on with that but all
right
you played the f5 played by Wei Yi that
makes sense right again I like the whole
approach here from Wei Yi just as far as
a a lecture on executing based on what
your opponent gives you right take what
they give you he he was dealing with the
big elephant center here and only took
on d4 once that night couldn't take the
most active square once that night was
no longer in position to guard the most
critical squares he changes the
structure by directly challenging the
lights course in the center with d5 and
just like that now he's gonna resupport
the strength of the five and just like
that I think I have a new co-host next
to me fade it can you hear me did it is
this a joke did it good talk buddy
good talk okay it's great man great to
have you yeah was it your did you just
did you troll me there could you hear me
the whole time no no I did not I just
had my mic as my speaker got it
that's right well first of all thanks
thanks for being here man I mean not
very often you see a super grandmaster
and twitch chat and invite him on your
show and they say okay I'm on EDX miss
you know yeah hey we need it whatever
what someone's got to cover a cover up
for Eric right I mean you know that's
usually a Mons full-time job but you're
here filling in anyway so we just had
our first win by Maxime and now we've
got what was a an ala pin kind of Rasul
emo Sicilian turned I think a little bit
wrong I feel like way he's about to get
some compensation in the form of an
attack on the kingside but maybe maybe
I'm wrong maybe H 2 and F 2 on as weak
as I
think they are what do you say see when
you take a look wait let me just make
sure that I'm in the right position okay
so is it a check right now he actually
just for side yeah so the next game is
under way and he just resigned because
Bishop d5 straight-up won a piece
actually everyone it attacks the Queen
and d3 is hanging so I had a sense that
black was in a good spot based on the
fact that there were some weak pressure
points here but it turns out the
problems were even worse so okay in the
in the live game vitta de we're
following another night or Sicilian g3
variation by way II can you can you see
the game 3 yeah the h3 line instead of
g3 which is what he played in game 2
right okay and still surprised that MBL
managed to save the first game I mean he
was completely lost in that end game
yeah the the the first time that he
played white in that rasa Lima right
yeah right well what are your thoughts
on Wei Yi the fact that he's going into
the night or fear against Maxime you
think that's a trend we'll see all day
normally normally people maybe avoid the
night or four against MBL what do you
think well if an issue was here he would
say that ambience night off and be
targeted so there you work with on each
am I allowed to say that yeah but he
regrets it but you do and you contribute
to his preparation your your is it fair
to say you've been his second in many
cases yes I contributed to mainly all of
his successes so does that mean we can
blame you for his opening repertoires
lack of bite but yeah honey she would
say that MBL's night or can be targeted
okay is that a foreshadowing of things
to come are we gonna look for a nice to
a challenge in beyond the night or f--
yeah well I don't work with him anymore
so
i gun him alright well that was the safe
answer all right well what do you think
Dee would you challenge on envy on the
night or firm what do you think about
way use approach here we've got this
positional assault on the queenside the
pawns on a5 and d5 I like White's
position here but I also like White's
position actually I mean ok for this
coming next which is a 9 so I expect
Knights if I to be played but then
Bishop d2
so it's not so 0 B 8 maybe maybe we
should be to first and then do k4 Bishop
d2 brach a for the main thing is that
black structure is just kind of broken
here right with the a6 and B four pawns
being disconnected in fact here he goes
for your plan yeah
maybe looking for right now shout out to
pay famoso who just gifted a diamond
membership in the chess TV chat to
walton 8 8 a I always love spreading the
love over there on chess calm okay
Brooke comes to a for now b3 but I
assume he'll play something like c4 oh
wow I thought I thought he would try to
strangle the pawn on b3 but he just
before makes sense okay that's something
that IMS do when they're offered a pawn
they get scared and don't take it with
it but I'm gonna learn that from you
this was a flip one and I like material
I'm like yeah sir in this way yeah I
like pawns are pawns right now you can
even trade on b8 and play b4 if you want
and just I mean absolutely completely
better for white and no compensation at
all I think I will just miss played
earlier I didn't see the opening
carefully but yeah you just miss played
I think yeah it's fascinating because I
guess we've been talking about Maxine
being known in the night work but you
said it onigiri believes that there's
some some potential targets here and
maybe wayy is on to something because he
looks like he's better here and I don't
think he was really much worse at all in
the first game either he eventually lost
cuz he miss played the extra pawn in the
obstacle Bishop position but but this
one looks very good for life I was just
getting it up they need to yeah join
this I missed that it was a weird one
because white was better better better
and then suddenly just just losing
so but yeah overall this looks like a
match where we may have way you
challenge em Beals night or today if
you're just joining us welcome we've got
Grandmaster video Gujarati and thanks
for being here guy just shows up here if
you don't know let's remind everybody
that bidded is one of the one of the
guys who'll be playing on October 4
through 6 and the official random a
World Chess Championship quarterfinals
competing for an opportunity to go to
Oslo and compete for the world
championship title so Vinit you made it
past Sergey Karjakin something that
Robert has a co-host of mine wasn't able
to do so that's why we have you here
right because apparently you're the
better choice
you know nobody come very close you know
he almost defeated him and as rooting
for Robert in that game when I was
watching it just been going on versus
blue bomb at that time right that was it
that was maybe the toughest the toughest
round you had but when you got past that
you ultimately won the whole bracket and
we're excited for you so alright if you
should have a lot of fun
the starting positions that are ugly but
once you get past that it's a lot of fun
to play right well how does weigh you
convert this safely right now are we are
we looking to play b5 as white obviously
you got this it might get to b5 is just
completely it's an improvement so right
now b5 a be Quinn b5 Luke c5 is his idea
so rooks you'll make sense yeah so maybe
now this is black preparing something on
c3 to get d5 is an exchange sac
completely out of the order no I think
it's just setting to take one d5 out
straight up yeah
connections doesn't probably work right
now Quinn b5 is met with Roxy v that's
when I'd be fight okay be 55 that is 97
tricks oh yeah probably if I expect an
identify to be played there's still
still some weirdness with the the
pressure on the diagonal there's tactics
with aces right yeah there is like we
should be 597 Quincy eight but probably
it doesn't work so I was wondering if
there's a six in her missive somewhere
six right now
and then you attack the b5
in the end she doesn't so the stage
woodworkers well you should be the queen
bee tree we need five is the point but
like white should just be winning I
think he could could you even trade
Queens on e8 and rush the a pond
no no need no no we should be three they
just lost I think we're going to see an
B I'll go down the game here and we
would be like cruising through this but
I see that Mae is playing really well so
far so it won't be easy yeah and you
wonder if he's going for this g3 night
or for a ch3 nitro fee he's obviously
prepared he's prepared to challenge
Maxine in his wheelhouse and if that's
something he's successful at then look
for the upsets yeah like the best chance
because the I think the shorter time
controls favored and we heavily right
that's what I've that you've played in a
speeches championship before right
previously your experience of that what
would be what was your favorite time
patrolling Lee's favorite time control I
like three plus one and bullet is fun
but it's really I mean I don't really
enjoy so much it's fun to play as
casually but not something which I would
like to have the match dependent on
right well we do our best to try to make
the competitive balance fair by making
the bullet only a half an hour compared
to the others but no for sure and we've
definitely seen a lot of matches like
yesterday's kind of come down to the
bullet right Sam Shanklin I think
perform better than a lot of people
thought he would first few games ding
one like the initial games in the green
field yeah and then I couldn't follow
the rest of it alright so we've got this
line that we've seen now become a little
more popular wear white allows this
Bishop trade
for the night on b1 and loses the right
to Castle what are your order your
thoughts on this line from a like a
blitz perspective White's dynamic
chances it's an interesting decision to
lose the right to castle but typically
the king is very safe on the light
squares right considered to be quite
pleasant for white yeah although it's
very quality but I remember one game
Magnus defeated Wesley in Y can say
which was very that that's what showed
the popularity of this line so there is
some when a minute I would not say that
it's completely harmless but I didn't
like the decision of CD now it's like
black ass very comfortable position just
97 yes so why is he taking d5 in this
floor is and isn't why normally playing
Bishop d3 King you to basically do the
same thing and maintain the tension
rather than trade so what is max seams
idea of taking here I really don't know
black I mean I would not mind playing
this position from black I guess on the
one hand white can play King f1 and came
g1 if he ever needed to complete the
castle by hand but this is Ouma almost
chess960 esque
not quite but you know 83 cos the threat
of night before and you're you're not
worried about Knight takes d4 everyone
cuz you can change yeah you win the
Queen he's allowing night before so he's
saying I want the transition of a knight
versus Bishop I would take it black yeah
and probably he doesn't like it so much
I think now white can be better slightly
because of this knight c6 which i didn't
like if doesn't look for it harmonious
okay and you wanted 97 earlier you even
said that is that because it prepared c5
no I just 97 c6 put the knight on f6 and
not somebody's you should I mean in the
same portion you would have knight on
design instead of d8 which makes more
sense right right no that makes sense
yeah just a better night on the although
the night will come to e6 and and maybe
there's some long-term idea where he
wants to trade the Knights on the King
side and have the Queen and Bishop do
some opposite code Bishop work
here see if the night comes t6 yeah it's
not that bad yeah kappa 96 or a 4 that's
the question okay
probably more playing for the draw going
for the trade with 95 if what is
slightly more ambitious so a 4 is like
saying I'm playing for a win here or did
not quite well it keeps more tension
that's what I would say ok the main
point now we have a nice little queen
pawn transition but probably why don't
be looking to play d5 at some point here
soon
yeah maybe 96 works d5 Knight c5
something like that me likey yeah I mean
if white gets d5 at night on d8 it's a
little bit annoying yeah the main thing
there everyone if white gets d5 the
night on T a completely gets restricted
and you don't really want to trade and
bring White's Bishop to the square so
indeed where Yi agrees we're getting the
line we predicted will we see Knight c5
indeed look at you vit it your first
speechless championship commentary and
you're calling all the moves it's
adorable
you're like you it's almost like you're
a really strong grandmaster or something
you know what this reminds me of what I
was watching the stream of you and uh
neesh okay and he says that do
everything but just don't compliment me
on my chest skills so now let me come
with you and your chest skills you can
okay good I will compliment your chest
goes by the way how's the Beehive you're
hanging out in like what's going on with
the honeycomb behind you are you um are
you okay okay so she's got interesting
taste that or your sisters would be
sorry where's your sister Abby no all
right what happened here is that Bishop
on h7 just happened and we looks
just just what he looks right now like
he's not on Form that's what he looks
like right he's about to go down to
games in this match but this is not so
easy to win but it should be technically
winning I feel okay maybe takes a 95 or
direct 95 either of these it goes
directly on c5 before there is some
counter play I would not be so sure that
this is winning because you know of this
pawns if the pond was on GSN it would be
much easier for black to play right okay
everything is safer maybe look a fade
right now would be six King g7 he goes
King ji-sun for us yeah and we already
said we've already seen Maxime hold a
game where he was down a piece and
ultimately got a draw but nobody
surprised and we'll keeps doing it all
the time I mean even in the real you
over the board chess yeah not at all
okay the rooks trading I guess that
probably yeah yeah it makes it easier
for black because these rooks are so
menacing but it's the same time you got
to get counter play here before white
just simplifies everything 95 is a nice
move Bishop f6 he'll play rook c7 check
yes ABI should be 694 we should be three
something like this I expect to happen
okay maybe there's 96 96 oh that's what
are you thinking about 96 and then F 3 C
4 ok well Sheila line 96 came takes F 3
the night comes here and eventually gets
in a position where everybody is guarded
so maxime not gonna play 96 probably
nicéphore but then Bishop takes a free
and I you know I would say in an
objective level probably black should be
winning this right but with with blitz
time controls and and not always the
perfect technique that may not happen
okay but here comes Brooke takes a three
now there's threats of rook a to and
look out for f2 9ft was a big strange
yeah kind of surrendering on all the
aggressive ideas yeah I don't know game
over
yeah it's what we've been talking about
here comes Brooke a - an F - and he's he
just he just busted indeed he is and he
just resigns Wow like himself at all too
many silly mistakes I mean the way he
blended the piece was so strange yeah
there was absolute need to do that well
we know max seemed kind of struggled
toward the end in st. Louis right and
those who followed us all Garry
Kasparov's comments where he said that
Maxime is kind of playing like a shadow
of himself right now as far as III saw
it more as a compliment I think some
people took it as kind of an insult from
Gary but I think he was saying that MBL
is clearly one of the best blitz players
in the world has been number one before
but he's struggled but how how tiring is
it right now to be a super grandmaster
with so many events and in is fatigue
something that could really be going on
for someone like MBL I think he told
that himself right I mean I saw some
tweet where he gave advice to Gary not
to play too much and he would be fine
something along those lines so he
himself agrees that he's been playing
too much which has been affecting his
performance and not hard to imagine yeah
that would be so well he's trying you uh
trying to keep the energy up though with
all that snacking will ask Maxime what
has preferred nuts are of choice this
this day but I'll as I said I'm going
almonds those tend to be his super food
but look at where Yi again if you're
just joining us he is challenged Maxime
in the night or for every game so far
not afraid to go directly into it right
now he's up two games so if you thought
oh another blow of a blowout somehow for
MDL I don't think that's what we're in
store for here today shout out to the
bits they're from from bill Tetley TV we
appreciate it
thank you so much alright again we've
got these I would say they're not the
sharpest lines always in the night or
but these these g3 variations you extend
the Jeep on what is what are your
preferred weapons against the night ourf
it's very easy to you with white and
actually I have one couple
of games with this system very easy to
play and again it looks like something
went wrong for Maxine Bishop b6 is
coming good move
yeah you've got g5 just barely yeah this
is crazy everyone this move 95 you if
you take here okay among other things
like taking a one there's also Bishop d6
almost immediately so II six is played
almost as an only movie oh wow Knight b6
Oh Bishop e6 would have been met by
Queen g5 so he plays Knight b6 I still
like white solution yeah I still like
White's position two and I still like
that just from a practical point of view
that way ye is coming after him in his
wheelhouse this is gonna be maybe an
interesting theoretical lesson for some
of our stronger viewers just to see
where Yi's approach to the knight orphan
may be making a recommendation on lines
we know that vidit you just said you
play these lines as white and you've won
some nice games as well worried about
that if you get a solid position from
the opening do you think you'll take on
a one I think at this point he maybe
should yeah because otherwise what do
you have right at least now you have a
rook but this just doesn't look good at
all for for black I mean some be castles
right now I think white castles what if
you just play simple chess castle put a
rook on d1 and just say my minor pieces
are better than your rooks right now I
would think white yeah but it's like
this shank lends game against England
you know where it can go easily wrong
when you're down material with this
Queen side you remember yeah yeah the
Queen takes e5 line you did watch
yesterday's show makes me so happy
that's why I joined today thank you
you're like if I'm gonna watch Danny I
might as well join and do some
commentary because ya know yeah but we
made that point right and you played in
this format so jokes aside there's that
you know where even if objectively we we
both agree that White's position is good
and the exchange sack is justified in a
practical gay game how often do you
see those advantages miss played and
then it just becomes easier to play with
the more powerful piece the queen of the
rook right it happens all the time under
it's not so easy to do that in this
position yeah this is a tough one for
Bart yeah so okay f6 is a principled way
to try to get the rooks going right if
you've got the rooks but it also
double-edged look at this let's show the
line nastiness about to come on the
board with Bishop e6 White's won back
the material in d6 is falling annually
he fights oh you'd love that wouldn't
you look at you you're getting greedy
I'm not so sure though 94 you know it's
a bit messy yeah maybe just take the D
pawn right trust the old guy here that's
being take material he likes a crisper
okay Knight f4 you called it but now
Bishop takes up four queen of four and
there's even moves like he's six wait
you wants I think I think he's just
gonna give up f2 Vinit yeah it looks
like he might do it queen of two king h1
if the bishop has to retreat White's
position in this epon just look crazy
dangerous maybe is technique maybe it'll
be six was simpler no yeah well I mean I
said rook t6 but he went with your move
so you know now maybe six Queen F
talking each one just I wanted to play G
fool but this just rook F one exchanging
the rooks oh he's going for advancing
with check and ship d5 was creative this
King at six o 95 one of these being at
6:00 and then rook f3 is it possible
King H 687 Queen f2 King H one rogue FC
oh wow let's show it
boom-boom rook f3 Bishop takes Queen
takes and black might just have a draw
very nice in fact that might be a key a
key swindle to save the day for Maxime
maybe you can play f1 or something like
now but it looks really weird yeah
video plays king h6 I think he spied
this line that Vitter just called there
okay but he he's gonna figure it out
what you want smore yeah this is a big
game for maxime Knight g4 yeah I love it
I know that it probably doesn't work but
I love it f3 just you have to play a
three and open up the Queen to guard all
the squares the what nice my gosh what a
find this is very good now he can take
with Chet but it doesn't matter the
Queen still responds with check that was
the whole point of the sack everyone
just take on a fee f8 and that's a
weiner feet well Maxime just resigned
before even waiting for Wei Yi to figure
it out unbelievable again we have
liftoff if you were looking for a match
everybody you're welcome
beta gujaratis here you wait you maybe
would have thought that score for Maxime
right possibly yeah this is fascinating
and I I said it in the quick free game
show vetted would we have two people
move on to the second round from China
we've never I don't believe we've ever
had a player from China even make it to
the second round yet in the sec both way
ye and Hoey fond pre competed previously
we were both eliminated in their first
rounds so this would be history you won
Dingley run won yesterday yeah so we
have we have we have ding li Ren already
in the second round and we'll where you
joined and we're gonna have an exciting
match as we find out you know venez not
commentating i was reading the chat and
one of the comments really caught my eye
it said is wei east camera freezed or
something because it's the same
expression yeah
no idea what's going on there we've got
some background but we were looking for
a nickname for Wei Yi we were coming up
with the Iceman cuz he's just frozen on
camera and his moves are stone-cold so I
don't know I mean I don't think he has a
nickname yet for the highest levels
that's kind of my thing is to give
nicknames that people don't want and
they're forced to accept that's kind of
my thing
so I don't know the Iceman I'm thinking
for ye what's your favorite I don't know
I mean I mean we would call Magnus mat
and mactown but again nobody like that
back town I think it mates that I'll
come up with a great nickname for you
though I think we're gonna go with the
wasp the what the wasp because of your
environment right now and also you sting
like a bee when you play chess no okay
okay yeah go ahead let's think on that
one for me all right yeah he's gonna
regain c5 and the center structure
definitely favors black FV yeah actually
that's a key point because now the
knight has to retreat before you can
take on c5 so maybe if you back up to f6
white gets Bishop d4 right and now
you're starting to grip on the dark
squares yeah although it's not the end
of the world maybe we should have 40
slightly better than Bishop d4 mm-hmm
gain a tempo you also take attack the FI
pawn like Quincy six there's ninety five
um cheeky stuff
I wonder if ye just missed a three
because suddenly he's gone to the think
tank and you and I both like black but
after a three now I'm not so sure yeah
we need seven is kind of forced and kind
of the only good looking move
yeah he plays in quickly 22 ease it ones
have done seem it seems like White has
solved his problems here maybe black we
would be for and try to get some
desperate counterplay with 95 ah but
it's like wait why does the bishop
coming to tea search right
yeah then you just suck it you know just
sack it right what all those fails maybe
Bishop g5 f6 Bishop at six need sense 98
so good move cuz it also prepares e5 for
black now right yeah 90s it's a good
move Oh II five days Bishop e5 wow that
would be crazy is that we should be five
yeah I think at the end of the line the
brookings nobody doesn't do it he just
backs up the bishop I'm curious if you
missed it am I missing something how
maybe this is night a c7 queen c3 d4 in
the in the end of the line we should be
threes probably right okay shout out to
our smarter chess predictions we'll talk
about that a little bit more but after
being an underdog wayy has now gone to a
favorite after this start so crazy turn
around with Wei Yi sort of shocking the
world right now with a three game lead
in our second speech chess championship
match of the year so if you're just
getting here don't go anywhere this
looks like it's gonna be a thriller who
knows maybe even a huge upset we've
never had a bean be - this game is
really important for him he has to win
it
otherwise the lead is too much yeah the
97 it's clearly better isn't it
just poor now
kake's be too
I was looking looking like Maxine might
stop the bleeding here get a win it's
quite simply queen before look at the
time
yes huge it baby became bit slow yeah
for some reason this game is like it's
like a weird like shift like the ebbs
and flows of the match it feels a little
slow and if Maxine wins it'll rally
rally the fans in France to say all
right Maxime is maybe recovering here it
could be my fault because we shaved him
in st. Louis maybe all the magic went
away with the beard that was that big in
the videos yeah
g5 right now go g5 you gotta you gotta
get aggressive as as black here a g5 and
then 95 is coming don't don't think so
much we just go for it
g5 where does that night go I don't know
I I didn't like c3 yes
95 trick yeah here it comes the c3 did
feel a little slow and you called it
look at this is this this how Wiggy
capitalizes on a blunder by Maxime I
think you have to play Queen d4 but then
Bishop takes c3 anyway is he gonna sack
his Queen I think he is I think he's
gonna play Queen d5 he does it oh my god
no for sure it's just I mean there's
Bishop e6 coming night on VIII's a
target rook a for what in the world is
going on right now Maxime is about to go
down four games in this match just
shocking
he just thinks that for them via well he
was he was playing well this game it
felt like the game that he turns things
around but as you said c3 was slow this
is just just busted like didn't do
anything just a WoW I'm like blown away
right now this is about to be a
four-game lead for the
underdog we've never had a 15 over a two
it doesn't happen in many brackets for a
reason but it might happen today I mean
yeah he's nice too there he goes he
takes a deep breath he needs to do
something if there's anybody listening
in his house maybe run in and just like
slap him like where he doesn't see it
coming just like really just like shock
him you know get him get him to wake up
cuz I don't know what else is gonna stop
him right now from finding he's finding
ways to lose I mean seriously VIN it
that fit that position was great for
white we were wrong right he was natural
but I mean there was only one trick for
black with g5 and it was not hard to see
at all yeah I mean here it's time to I
mean I really don't know what's going on
probably it's just like this series of
losses you have in blitz which really
gets your head yep I don't imagine him
we're doing such things otherwise too
much too much high-level chess in 2019
not enough puzzle rush missing easy
tactics you know by the way have you
seen our new puzzle battles feature no
what's that maybe we'll try to make you
a staff account and throw down today
what we have you will see it's um it's a
pretty awesome new feature but it's
where you basically play you play puzzle
rush against somebody you get the exact
same puzzles and you're it's like like a
live match like you would play blitz but
but you're both racing ants the same
series of puzzles oh that's it's still
it's still in beta but will be out soon
so IB IB Robert hessin it and then we
try to do it again and he threw a
tantrum on screen and like refused to
play and everyone was like what's wrong
with Robert and they remembered he was
throwing a tantrum because he was so
embarrassed about losing to me I hope
he's listening right now so this again
reminds me of something between your
match with your community with a niche
where someone commented that Robert
Hayes is a much better commentator than
uh nish and then onions got told heavily
in the comment section once he decided
to you know talk about it in in the show
has the niche talked to you about his
obsession with Robert by the way in
general
I mean he texts me pictures anytime he
finds like a sign that says chess and he
removes the C to make it say Hesse he
talks about like Hesse calm s24 calm
he's texting me stuff he's obsessed with
Robert so I think it's that we need to
talk to Aneesh about this all right well
again wayy looking great he's got the
bishop pair he cleans up the Queen side
by taking c5 I don't see a clear way
black gets c4 back bishop d4 now seems
pretty classic I would blunder okay
Bishop d4 rook t2 would be a fork there
you past visit one of the one of it one
of the tests of the co-commentator is
quickly catching Danny's blunders you
just jumped a level buddy okay Brooke c8
I guess this is where the compensation
comes in it's hard for white to defend
c4 and a - yeah imagine that black has
enough countably in this position yeah
okay hu falls how do you take it queen
or rook yeah there you go and it's still
an unclear position though right I mean
white does have the bishop pair and one
of the things you'd love to get is white
is something like f4 to dislodge the
knife and obviously it's it's it looks a
bit shaky yeah and if it works it's
really nice because then you get Queen
g4 as well yeah the knight moves and
then then you get Queen g4k he plays c5
but still watch out for f4 everyone is a
double-edged move but maybe c63 okay
good move rook t3 threatens to win a
piece here ooh did he miss it
oh wow Maxime Maxime goes did I just get
a blunder right c5 you probably just
some way oh my gosh unlucky if you're
Maxime he's like what I can't get your
break he blunders and it doesn't matter
all the way he pretty much always looks
like this game bores him like he should
have chosen go or something if chess is
as easy as way he makes it look you know
yeah or UFC quindi it is like windy it
in this position our queen da might
still win the piece Mac seems thinking
about it
we need a if he saw it you would have
played it he did yeah okay this is a
very nice tactic windy eight this is
very important because again if you're
just joining us and you're like wait are
those is that a typo no the score is not
wrong way he is up four games in this
match with only 25 minutes remaining in
the five-minute portion but I think I
think he gets the one here I know I said
that last game where he was better and I
ended jinxed him but it looks like
Maxime is about to strike back yeah I
mean Queen DT also doesn't work so maybe
just Ruby 5 in this position trying to
sack the Queen and hope to get some
counter play maybe f4 I don't know just
go desperate with white right now
maybe f4 yeah f4 looks interesting
oh this monk is unhappy with me in the
chest TV chat clearly an MV l fan says i
jinxed him again i don't think so i
think he gets this one now he's
threatening rook takes c3 watch out for
that which will end up being a fork of
the king and rook yeah the c-4 is
irritatingly strong would you take one
e3 to just simplify but it's too much
maybe just rook c7 and what slowly yeah
rook c7 as long as Bishop a4 is not a
problem I guess you can just play Bishop
e5 yeah he decides here's a bet for a
before I think Bishop e5 then
takes and Queenie for oh yeah very
dangerous before okay that's the point
the Bishop f4 doesn't work sorry say
that again be sure before is met by what
Ruby for rock d4 okay did you you know I
think we're gonna get some sort of SAC
now or either that or again we'll use
having his first game of blunders but
speaking of first vetted fun fact for
you Wei Yi this year has never trailed a
single SCC match he won
every juniors features championship
match and never trailed it ultimately
took him overtime to win it took him
overtime to win the finals which was
amazing but he never trailed and he's
never trailed in any of his J SCC
matches and he has a trail today either
so Oh a site with the final were Jeffrey
okay I think last year he had a bad draw
I mean he faced akaru in the first round
itself so good for him then this year he
is going so far yeah he's had a great
year so I guess I guess okay in the
final versus Jeffrey Zhang at one point
he did fail but he ultimately won sorry
he did trail but he ultimately won but
other than that he's really had a great
year and been impressive so yeah I guess
if he loses this one then that then the
tread then the crowd can get mad at me
for jinxing MBL if he finds a way to
lose this one that I'm the problem
not MBL's chess but I think the chances
are low of that happening although it's
still tricky but I mean at least LLL not
lose you might not win it yeah people
just tuning in everyone pointing out
it's surprising to see the score but
where has played fantastic so far and
mvl not so much
we should be fine Quinby three trying to
get some win be seven if white gets the
a 7 point it's not easy
white should try to do that yeah it
would be super hard to win that again
and one of the reasons everyone is
tonight is just not not the best piece
when it comes to try to convert in an
end game like that where your pawns are
already doubled in week so we're just
gonna take a moment here try to think of
the best way to make it hard for black I
don't like Quincy 6 because now then
black got rid of the pin so that's why I
wanted Quinn b3 with the same idea same
idea of going to be 7 yeah it's a nice
move with Queen a5 by mvl he's inviting
the trade because this would fix the
pawn structure on double the G pawns and
now 85 I'm expecting if I rub c5
aha can we be one check and I don't have
any follow-up actually Queenie seven
irritating because you're actually
threatening rook c5 right now yeah so
maybe not something like night at six we
net for that's a good move
that's a good move oxy six five rook c5
Google Queen d6 trying to force the
ladies off the board but we're Yi says
not so fast 936 Quincy for something
like this 986
yeah it's it's still it's still hard for
for maximum now maybe you can play
Knight at five right you slowly improved
your knight yeah maxime agrees idealist
yeah looks like he's slowly working his
way over
sometimes this happens when you're off
form right it feels like every win is a
just a super difficult game to get right
takes a long time to find to find your
form yeah indeed but this no it's easy
maybe ninety four look at Viking g8 and
a 94 you have to be careful about things
like rook h5 and Queen c4
yeah 96 I thought it's working he goes
for it he's gonna get twenty four ninety
six and I think then rook d5 win super
Queenie success well that's more P then
if I was yeah maybe you were right maybe
Queen e6 was better but okay well you
still keeping a tricky with only six
seconds you you gotta admit he's handled
the time scramble as well and I don't
know if you followed the junior speeches
championship but when he beat firoozeh
everybody was shocked right at way yeah
upsetting all the resolution but one of
the things he did well and that match
was handled himself in time scrambles I
mean in many ways he he won the time
scramble battles against firoozeh so
I've been super impressed by wiggies
performance okay although here he goes
down and all right maxime stops the
bleeding I
can no longer be blamed for jinxing him
much like I was blamed for ruining a
nice Geary's career when he joined me
for commentary if you have some bad
tournaments after this I don't want to
be blamed for it when does it need not
have bad tournaments he and I talked
about all the time that somehow this guy
has though this guy has the worst
tournaments yet somehow maintains World
Number Four all the time no just kidding
but he actually I know I'm kidding he
said he had a bad tournament but with
that victory over Yan in the last round
he actually did end up plus one so
speaking of tournaments let's talk about
you so we know you're playing in the
Fischer random role chess championship
when is your next tournament but is it
the Fischer random quarterfinals is
there something in September here I seem
like I leave in couple of days for that
okay so the World Cup obviously big one
we hope you go all the way there right
and then and then miss the Fischer
random quarterfinals but after that
after the quarter after the World Cup
the quarterfinals for the Fischer random
will just championship you're also
playing at the feet HS calm grand Swiss
right the Isle of Man yeah yeah writing
that yeah we know you're a fan of the
Isle of Man last year you and I got to
go over a couple of your games you like
it there it's fun it's fun I'm not
coming this year because I have a wife
and four kids that would I have to go
directly from our company meetup which
is in Mexico this year to Oslo Norway
for the for the world championship for
the Fisher random so if I was in Isle of
Man 2 I would literally be gone for
almost a month and so I'm I'm probably
gonna be a part of the commentary team
right here from Studio C doing some sort
of remote Colin
maybe we'll get you in an interview but
no I will not be at the Isle of Man live
some all right so what's going on here
psychologically vetted we've got a big
win there for Maxime even the way he has
the lead right he definitely wants to
keep that because he knows as the timer
controls get faster what a beast MBL can
be so what do you think both players are
thinking about here usually what happens
is after losing the first game you
only because your confidence is slightly
shaken right if you lose the him again
you know you even play most low so this
game is quite important if he holds this
he'll restore his confidence okay
and it looks doable right now what's
what's the time left for this section so
we've got 17 minutes right now pretty
much exactly so it's possible we could
only have one more game after this
depending on how long it goes right a
given that it just started I think we'll
get at least one more what's this called
prediction after the 5:1 yeah I'm gonna
call 6-3 I think Maxime gets another win
and we get a draw 6-3 where you going
into 3-1 that's my prediction
if max isn't going to be on three and a
half I'm not good at math I'm gonna
guess six four all right so I was
looking at good at score thinking he'd
only get a half a point but that's your
your fearless chief chess officer here
leading the way with math all right
[Music]
yeah they make fun of me all the time
you know the all right Knight to b6 is
played what does white got here I was
laughing with you that's okay high
school dropout proud of it you know all
right Knight b6 we've got maybe some
queen c1 yeah you got a deal with b2
right yeah I mean I just want to play
Bishop c3 I'm not like this no just win
d1 and takes on c3 I don't like what
they did the way you just said not like
this you sounded like switch from the
matrix what you know the scene where
they all start getting unplugged from
the matrix and die because the guy goes
bad and they just start pulling the
plugs you know I might sound like a
really boring guy because I don't
remember matrix I mean I haven't seen it
but I don't remember anything and she's
like not like this
not like this so anyway you sounded like
switch there but that's okay I hope it
was a good thing it was a cool moment
sad moment but cool and kind of like
that position there because you didn't
like bishops III played in that move
order let's talk about why I mean why
would you do that you've got the bad C
pawn so why did he do it I mean going to
c1 he seemed like he had time maybe now
just ninety six it's still slightly
better for white there's some pressure
but I would not have played Bishop c3
and during my pawn structure 94 is good
move
interesting maybe now 95 let's go for c4
c4 I think we're gonna get your 95 the
question is do you ever want to take on
c6 here's why to return the favor and
give your black bad pawn structure no no
not at all I mean I don't see five or
something
dozen I don't need three but that's not
happening okay so he's gonna try to get
the pawn to c5 in some of these
positions right make b7 weak and okay
yeah me now just Bishop g4 and then the
rope to see it and like is completely
fine that needs to get the rukon c8
so white has one more move to strike
with some sort of initiative yeah he
wants wants to get the knife from a
three maybe two C four and then a five
right trade off c6 so you can gang up on
b7 this is a good option so Bishop e6
maybe
yeah he goes oh he doesn't make the
trade but it's cuz he's getting pressure
on c6 but what's the we we should be
fine yeah Bishop d5 I was about to ask
what's the deal with Bishop d5 but we're
gonna find out cuz he plays it oh I'm
I'm not good at guessing envious most
today I could be a bad thing about MDL
though not you so maxime not playing his
best chess right now at 6:00 now no
absolutely no reason why white should be
better at all he's getting these good
positions and then just in few moves
he's spoiling it yeah
and it's been kind of a trend today he's
been too fast like killing critical
positions yet so much time in India
utilize it well that's what I feel no
it's a good observation he's been up on
time consistently yet down on the
scoreboard right this is a one of those
cases where maybe Maxime just playing
too fast overall and we've seen wayyy
convert on advantages despite little
time on the clock so right now black has
a good spot with a nice bishop in the
center of the board are you thinking
about a place rook d8 I was wondering if
you're gonna play something like rook b2
at some point to try to renew the threat
of taking a - yeah this this way also
makes sense to exchange the rooks and
now maybe Bishop a5 just broke e4 is
also an option and then go Bishop e6
back
yes loose Lanai Dre please you
vulnerable I like that how to improve is
the question
I don't like before so much doesn't do
much 24 yeah move it almost optically
looks good but does nothing yeah just
aim though just half a minute
can go down for me yeah that would be
huge for Maxime obviously he miss played
the position is white but a winner win
is what he needs right now he needs a
win if Bishop f5 is a threat at the
moment not so easy to counter that this
night only trees
so of you so really yeah I mean okay how
do you untangle I don't see a clear way
yeah you can dc2 is met with Bishop f5
again
that's annoying what about Lucy for can
you get away with Knight c2 at some
point to try to head to be for and hit
c6 I know it's horrible and that's c4
yeah it's horrible to allow the pin okay
he pushes King e1 perhaps he's trying to
get the King in a spot where it could
protect the rooks like King d1 okay but
that would that was run into nice e3 so
just kidding never mind don't put your
king on d1 no maybe four yeah maybe it's
needed
your Kings are guarding d2 so you are
technically in a position to play Knight
before now in fact he goes for it right
because now the whole point is the trade
on d2 I started to trade on c1 that king
guards d2 and actually that's a nice
transition here for Maxime yeah and I
didn't like this before yeah we're gonna
have a time scramble now and Maxime
maybe has a chance to strike a second
point here it should probably be a draw
objectively but time is even objectively
better ninety three and go with the king
or king C three kings e4 in this double
bonds clearly better in Game four white
good chances and we eat ARR child acting
c3 King see four ninety five ninety
seven ninety three let's see what
happens
it fixes it first that's a nice idea
right makes f5 permanently week he'll
take with the pawn so 90 three hits it
and then King be if I that's the
plan yeah yeah 93 will force King e6 and
then King before King a5 once you've got
these two weaknesses as if it was saying
okay now you can just play 93 and then
king b5 and that's what he does I think
he's gonna get it win in here this could
be two victories in a row Maxime is uh
on the rebound
probably you can just move the king and
push the a pawn right and forget that
for King B 685 I would just you know I
know but come on King b6 is what you
know that's what me a Maxine would play
and he does it
the you would you would play the safe
move no kidding last game was that we
got to long time I mean we just have a
minute
and it just what I was so quickly but
what does that do for your confidence
when you know you're off form that it's
so okay there's it's nice to get a big
win when you just blow somebody off the
board right but what does it do for your
confidence when you know you've been
struggling were you basically what did
Maxime do there he took a worse position
as white slowly worked his way back in
had to defend this King e1 plan and
eventually one is sometimes winning a
game like that that it was a real
struggle more important for your
confidence when you're off form if it
was me I would not be so happy because I
knew that I was clearly was in that game
I mean probably objectively even lost so
my confidence would still be shaken the
first at his place and at the moment
okay but that doesn't help to make you
feel like alright well at least I'm I'm
defending when I'm down right I mean
from a psychological perspective it's
it's how do you write the ship when you
know you're off form if you can't defend
bad positions right yeah but having said
that what I mentioned then I look that
okay I've got three and a half now
I'll be happy again this course matters
a lot right and we've got seven half
minutes so we'll see if my prediction
was right the second one before the
after the bad man maybe if we get its
raw here that'll be six to four
potentially as we head into the
three-minute portion so if you're just
joining us we got five thousand of you
with us thanks for being in here is the
second speech Chess Championship match
of the year alongside me super
grandmaster video Gujarati we've talked
about his schedule he's got World Cup
then he's got the Fisher random world
chess championship coming up October 4
through 6 as the quarterfinals I mean
even if you get last place on October 4
through 6 it's still like 10 grands so
congratulations you made it and if you
make it to Oslo your pet you're playing
for six-figure money so exciting stuff
and
and then you've got the feed a chest
hungry and Swiss at the Isle of Man yeah
and congrats for having such a cool
tournament like Fischer random I like
that idea
yeah thank you it's been it's been
obviously a very controversial
tournament in some ways the first of its
kind to be an online qualifier that
allows us to kind of say to the general
world that everybody had a chance if
they wanted to compete
obviously you kind of know that the best
players in the world at chess are
probably still the best players in the
world of Fischer random so we're not
surprised let's bring up the eight faces
that are playing in the quarterfinals
we're not surprised to see a whole lot
of familiar faces competing for the big
money
because you guys are super GM's for a
reason but still it was a very unique
event a lot of fun and now that we're
down to the the guys you see there I
don't even know I would have a hard time
predicting the three players who will
qualify for Oslo to join Magnus Carlsen
so other than yourself who do you think
are some of the best players in the in
the official random format that you're
facing but actually you know it's funny
that I don't even understand the format
yet I mean I don't know if it's going to
be eight versus eight I don't know how
the four players are going to qualify
I've no Q sorry
hey that's a great question because I
don't even know if I know no kidding I
do know it's uh it'll be an initial
round where then the the top six kind of
qualify for like a second round-robin to
come up with three winners that will
alternately go to Oslo so a bit
complicated indeed but our best version
of trying to get the format that the
organisers in Norway do nee s and feat a
wanted so anytime something is like you
know slightly weird with the format I
just say hey it was doing a yes and
fides idea I'm kidding but it's been a
great event and we're super proud and
happy to be a part of it and you know
what before my match I didn't even know
like how it works like how do how do I
guess in after playing few games I
realized that okay you put the King on
the rook and that's how it guesses right
yes that means you didn't watch my video
on how to extract how do you explain
castling and online you just put your
king on the rook and that does it for
you but
you know that yeah I'll give you a link
to my videos buddy don't worry alright
well it joking here but we've got
another night over again Wei Yi not
afraid to go directly into the the
wheelhouse so to speak this time that
he's been working well for him via very
comfortable position night is coming to
e4 okay maybe something like nine g4 is
interesting but still there's I mean
there's the a file for white and the
b-pawn is a target I guess black and you
dig on d5 and you dig on d5 is the
question oh well that would be quite
risky to just self pin he does it
apparently you were right he just grabs
the pawn and says I'm not afraid of the
pin I'd be afraid of the pin before
that's the point you blocked you block
the diagonal very nice in fact but it's
not before before it's too messy yeah
super tricky so the idea everyone eat
right now the night is being double
attacked in this pin so e4 kind of
forced but as fit it said here comes b4
and if the knight moves then the e pawn
is hanging yet again as the knight is
it's only protector so instead after e4
Wow work a7 oh this is a good move 26
then 94 its completeness yeah this is a
94 hits the Queen after you move it is
their night at 578 okay I was I was
assuming Queen e8 but okay you're right
maybe 27 holds at 5 and I would start
that is an option okay wow he goes to e8
but but now the move I was worried about
Knight a5 is an option which hits e7 and
unleashes an attack on d5 Knight is a
good move because Luke c7 you probably
allow 97 yeah wonder why Maxime went for
this what does he see here now Queen
takes hits g7 and that's 25 then
but still rook c7 and then Duquesne so
win g5 Roxy Sunday's Queen everyone
check oh yeah yeah you wouldn't cut the
real good check that's key will show
that it takes Queenie five takes here if
you were to take rook e8 and Queen h5 is
mate but you take a one with check in
term is oh and everybody wins if you're
black so and yes out swindling is
opponent and here he goes he plays e5
guards the spot on g7 hits a one
actually I wonder where he miscalculated
this now he's pausing for a think and I
feel that there was something for white
and he missed blade yeah
I feel something went wrong there maybe
maybe your before maybe your before was
better than rock a7 which is so tempting
when you see it that you have to play
right yeah especially cuz everything
comes with tempo rook a 794 yeah it just
feels like the pieces are coming to life
well he's got more tactics and we're not
out of the out of the woods yet or for
MBL probably you put the King on f8 I
don't see anything
yeah he's defending and now everything's
being traded black is already up a pawn
remember everyone he's already done the
math on that so the trade perhaps g6
know you don't want allowed 96 is some
counter play left 96 is hard to meet a
superior take maybe takes and would be 8
what about that we're gonna eat first
same idea
AHA but now you have 96 if you want as
well ye know but then takes and E 4 is
hanging this is Ruby bond yeah I forgot
my knight the
Duty over here on e4 Wow
will ye keeping the pressure again very
little time he continues to play
accurately aggressive moves you seven
now yeah rook d7 might be forced to put
the rook on a protected square oh look
how quickly he plays it just goes right
back to threatening a back rank
checkmate
you can also play King g8 but yeah f6
would free the back rank King g8 runs
around as long as black and hold the e4
pawn here it seems like Max team's
position will be just fine but no I
think this is such a big black will win
and the portion is good as well I don't
know I always get afraid of making those
predictions just because of the
increment changes everything in these
settings and obviously way you work
super hard on his opponents time so but
yeah I mean at this point seems like
blacks should be able to hold because
he's up a pawn now before is a
possibility and he allows it giving up
before what's he what's he have here
okay he's just trying to unwind I guess
at the willingness to sakip on I like
what black did because there was some
counter play if they are flicking Jade
or f6 with like Luke on the last rank
this makes sense what MBL did my
prediction could be wrong we could have
four and a half five and a half and a
storm right back by the way the the this
is officially the last game in the
five-minute portion the time is up
position wise black is white is fine I
feel because Luke a7 is coming but the
time is just terrible I mean you cannot
play with one second just she's gonna
try and oh he makes that move with 0.5
on the clock no I'm here we'll win it
yeah he'll take 85 safely now yeah but
one second yeah and it's a consistent
thing I don't like it yep to always pick
one second well I was working earlier
when it felt like Maxine was almost
playing too fast if you're just joining
us at some point in the
match way he was up for games five and a
half one and a half we've never had
somebody be down for games and a speed
chess match at least the official format
since we launched the SCC VIN it and
come back and win today could be history
maybe Maxime did it on purpose just so
he could set that record okay let's not
go too far but no I I'm kidding of
course you just want to be down but if
he did come back and win this would be
the first time that anyone came back
from a four-game deficit yeah that would
be impressive
of course you needed a little bit of
luck but to come back like this it's not
easy I remember in my match against
Wesley yeah two points down and it was
not easy to come back what is this end
game he's up on is it gonna be wearing
f6 king f7 exchange tonight it's very
tough objectively also black might be
just winning yep why is it the night I
came very close to King upon ending okay
he does make that move barely in time so
what would be your plan here to win if
you were black just play around a bit
yeah I think you that's what happened
but I wanted to know what your actual
chess plan was because the answer play
around a bit it went on time is what
happened but even g5 okay so is it but
here's the thing do you put the knight
on f5 first to maybe keep the King stuck
and then try for g5 where the trade
happens and then you have h4 this sort
of thing and I don't before actually
okay so then if I put my gonna fight
this g4 for white which exchanges one
more pawn okay so you don't need four
and when when another plan is to bring
the King to d3 you know something like
this okay you slowly slowly kick the
knight out bring the came to a more
active Square so I think it's
instructive I know that the knight
impugn endings are supposed to be close
to King and pawn endings in the sense
that normally you you have great winning
chances here even if even if best
defense can sometimes hold but we're
never gonna find out because MVL wins on
time find out food enough no it doesn't
look so bad yeah only down by a game but
if you're just getting here it was a
huge lead for the Chinese but the man
from France comes all the way back we
have a one-game lead a four-way ye
headed into the three-minute portion a
close match here in our second speech s
championship event of the year
we'll be right back hopefully with video
Gujarati sticking right here with me but
don't go anywhere the three-minute is
coming right up
[Music]
welcome back everyone chest coms speed
chess championship continues here is our
second match of the 2019 season
yesterday we had Dingley Rennes hold on
and get by the American Sam Shanklin the
first person from China to ever reach
the second round on her own SCC but
let's talk a little bit about the junior
speaches championship and the path that
Wei Yi took to get here obviously we
know that hehe turned a lot of heads
when he got by I'm gonna go right to
that second round matchup sorry the the
semifinal matchup overall the rezident
firoozeh he also be pregnant and uh of
course yordan Vaughn for East but really
that one where he beat Olly Reza
firoozeh was the one that kind of made
everybody lift their eyebrows I think he
shocked a lot of players and really
because of the way he did it he held his
own in time scrambles and said hey I'm
not just gonna be outplayed in these in
these wicked resourceful kind of tricky
time scrambles and and even ultimately
held on against faroush and bullit it
wasn't until he played Jeffrey's young
that way he had ever trailed in a single
match in the J SCC and the ultimately
came back in one in our first-ever armor
get an overtime event of any SCC so just
a reminder of how impressive way Yi's
path has been to get here and how
excited we are to see what he can do
against mvl in the faster time controls
Before we jump into the three-minute let
me remind everybody of the daily
question and I want to clarify a little
bit of what I think is cool about our
idea here because we're really
considering this so I really would
appreciate your feedback please use the
hashtag speech s to give us some actual
comments on it we'll give you a diamond
membership and maybe show your tweets on
air I promise you because one of the
thoughts we've had about not only the
format we already have which is that
every game is worth at least a little
bit of money part of the prize fun is
guaranteed but part of the prize fund
forces the players to continue to always
think about the effort they're putting
in and it's not any sort of shade
against any other format but we know
that shed at the highest level often
leads to a lot of draws because it's
hard to win games against players that
don't blunder so by making every game
count for something it's something we
think makes the format more exciting
while they race against the counting
down clock but we're also considering
whether draws should counted all toward
the total score and
maybe find a way that the prize money
gets more significant for every game
they draw and makes the next game
perhaps worth more adding a little bit
more of interesting intrigue they're so
curious on your thoughts about that if
it's necessary if you'd like it if you
don't if you don't even use Twitter you
can hold your mouse over the twitch
player here and vote be the extension
which of course is a fun way to do it so
no excuse give us a vote let us know
your thoughts and we look forward to it
so video Gujarati has it had an
appointment there with his a sister for
dinner so we're hoping to have the super
Grandmaster from India back here and in
just a little bit later on in the show
so your coast with you here flying solo
thanks for being with me
Maxime looks like he still got snacks so
nobody panic Wei Yi also put on his
glasses apparently he played the entire
five minute blindfolded so now the stage
has been set it's a one-game lead for
the Chinese and three minute is about to
get underway
and just a moment right as I say it's
almost like they're waiting for me to
say words like get under way almost like
I'm magically behind when the games will
start here we go efore and that thank
you be with us all 5,000 w wherever
you're choosing to watch please hit that
follow button for the biggest most
exciting event coverage in chess right
here at twitch.tv slash chess and chess
comm TV alright we've got another
Rhossili mo we've had this all day if
you missed the memo
maxime played white and the sicilian
several times and every time he has
played Bishop b5 check Wei Yi in Game
one played Bishop d7 since then he's
transitioned to 90 d7 and now we're
gonna get a different line still in a
love pin structure where white plays for
C 3 and d 4 we talked about the ideas of
this white wants to get a big Center and
keep it rather than exchange it as you
do in open sicilians c3 prepares the c2
square for the bishop and it's a very
nice very very kind of safe structure
for white not the most challenging in
the sharpest theory but e 5 is also a
very committal approach to the structure
one of the reasons is that if and when
the smoke clears let me just show what
could happen White has the outpost
square d5 to access whereas black
doesn't have d4 and also doesn't have a
knight on the normal square that it
would come to tea
use that square so this can be a
positional disaster sometimes for black
in fact on that note we actually see
Maxime has taken on e5 in the live game
after trading d7 and I I'm speaking from
experience here when I say that I've
I've lost on the black side of these
structures more times than I'd like to
tell obviously a Sicilian player for
life hashtag thug life and also a a
nimza player and sometimes again story
systems Tori London's you can actually
get similar structures as black and d4
and one of the issues is that white gets
the more control even with this move c4
white is getting to d5 before black gets
the d4 and that's kind of the key point
he's gonna exchange here and have the
positional edge of the knight being more
dominant there and black being a little
bit behind and trying to do the same
thing so again I know diamond remember
real greco shocked to find out that I've
ever lost any chess games in my life but
yeah I've lost positions like this more
times than you would think so it's a
good positional lesson every time and I
feel like I I think that black should be
fine objectively but on a structural
level I think MBL got the better hand of
that exchange and I could see it coming
the moment a5 was played it's a very
committal way to play in these Sicilians
and I think white has the edge here so
so there you go
we'll see if Maxime pressure presses and
improves me right about the edge or of
way he has something in store to show us
why blacks position isn't as bad as I
think it is we'll find out the diamond
member a VLPs one won a whole lot of
number says Valentina goo Nena beat
chess Queen down four I was I was kind
of referring to the main sec that we had
never had since we launched it I was
talking about the three years of the sec
there were also other four-game matches
as well Irina crush came back and won a
four game match the Sasha vltava
actually came all the way back from a
four-game action well so in the format
we have had others I was referring to
the main sec but I do appreciate the
correction there I know I know you're
looking forward to when I'm wrong so but
that's what I was referring to was the
main sec but yes we have had four game
comes back come back
for but MBL if you're just joining us
was down four games in this particular
match here he would be the first one to
do it in the main sec so all right beef
I played by Wei Yi and he's trying to
target these double pawns as
compensation for the fact that he's
already sacrificed one but what does NVL
have in store after Bishop T - what if
oh he's got Knight if six coming oh wow
he's got dark squares on the mine made
on the brain right that's actually a
really hard thing to deal with in fact I
wonder why you missed it Bishop d2 we
see Maxime kind of confidently sitting
back let me just show the line of Queen
b-59 f6 check I either win the exchange
via fork emote or you take and I mate
you on everyone's favorite spot over
here this is a problem in fact so much
so the way he just sacrificed the
exchange because he couldn't give up the
dark square control fascinating okay now
now if white has time you'd like to get
Bishop g5 Bishop f6 and exchange off
more pieces particularly the dark square
Bishop because black does have some
compensation here don't kid yourself
right B threes weak you've got pressure
on it if that falls you've got two
passers if I've played kind of the same
idea I would I would hope for for white
to put the bishop on f6 yeah but it's
it's hard to know if white is really
that much better here I think white is
but d3 cuts off the communication of the
Queen to b3 so black is black is trying
to take one of the risks though if you
took and I don't know if this was
possible right away but you self pin so
there's ideas on f7 over here could get
some really really weird stuff even east
six taking advantage of the pin bishop
so that's not what happened rookie to d1
Bishop h6 black wants d2 and shout out
to Wei Yi who found a way to sacrifice
that exchange but maintain a super solid
structure with some with some potential
here I don't know that white could lose
this game without a blunder from here
but but it is hard to see how mvl has a
straightforward plan let's draw our
attention to time for the first
I'm in the three-minute portion here
because it's about 30 seconds of an
advantage on the clock for Maxime and we
know that he was up on the clock and
pretty much every game in the
five-minute portion if you missed it so
if if he continues to see that trend in
the faster time controls way he could
get in trouble but again way he has not
won in almost an hour he was up five and
a half one and a half and Maxime came
all the way back to have the score that
it is now five and a half four and a
half so way he needs to needs to strike
back here
okay rook comes to d4 he renews the
threat on p3 I like it
Queen e3 trying to get to e7 that's a
problem if your way you got to be
careful about that it's always nice to
spy squares like that in your opponent's
camp when you have an extended pawn keep
your eye out for tactics because a trade
would lead to a new lady but Wei Yi
quickly play Queen d8 like he saw it
coming he's hitting f6 and maybe he
wants a trade I still have a good
feeling about maximum position here I
feel like rook a7 is possible okay b4
undermines the protection of the rook is
he gonna try to overload the Queen Wow
Queen takes f6 takes e5 the rook can
come to d2 and there's no devastating
discovery no he doesn't he agrees here
comes rook a 7 I think and f7 is gonna
be a problem in a lot of lines rook a 6
overloading the Queen's protection of
the rook perhaps even better yeah I'm
not surprised the way this converted not
just because of the clock I also felt
like Maxime had the edge here for some
time it just was gonna take a while to
deal with the compensation black could
achieve now we've got f3 and g4 is an
idea taking his time but I think that I
think there should be a straightforward
way to transition if the Queen's come
off the board white is easily winning
right now he's threatening Queen e5 very
very nice technique actually in fact I
think that's gonna bring the game here
any moment he plays Queen e5 and yeah
with the ladies off east 6 and then c6
too many passed pawns not enough time
Maxine will take this game and if you
wanted a wild one right we had a four
game lead for Wei Yi four straight
victories for Maxime vache The Grove and
guess what ladies and gents we have a
tight match five thousand viewers don't
go anywhere I think we're gonna be in
for an exciting one but it's time for
wayy to prove that this isn't gonna be a
landslide the other direction he has to
stop the bleeding he continues to play
for the knight effort now he's going
into the sharpest line so we're gonna go
poison pawn queen d - come on do it
poison pawn it is okay Queen D 3 is
still it's not the most theoretically
known lines but this is a this is one of
the sharpest most
ethically prepared lines in the night
orph in the history of the game I'll
analyze it quickly just to set the tone
of exactly what's going on but but
quickly so let's look at this Queen to
b6 the point is black is trying to
expose the pawn on b2 to punish white
for this really early development if
white does any sort of passive moves to
defend it then you're ruining your right
to castle long black can instantly start
striking against the center knight c6 e
five comes so very often white is gonna
develop the Queen to either d3 or d2 and
just sacrifice b2 in order to gain an
initiative that you now see on the Queen
f5 and Queen a5 this is typical stuff
where black is having grabbed the pawn
in a rush to regroup get everybody back
to safety and hold on to the extra pesky
but the initiative becomes super crazy
for white well you took his time there
before taking e6 I I don't even know all
the theoretically all the theoretical
roads we might get here this line after
taking f7 King takes is met by Queen c4
and you take c8 all I know is I'm kind
of surprised to see where you go for
this he's clearly a little frustrated by
the fact that he hasn't gotten a win in
a while because he's been consistently
playing these g3 night offs the h3 nine
ourf he hasn't been afraid to challenge
maxime in the sharpest Sicilian but this
is the first time we've seen him go go
full full really really sharp Sicilian
against Maxine exciting he's down a
piece I think Maxine will play King d8 I
think that's okay King b7 the same idea
you avoid take F set your voice 7 not to
lose the bishop on c8 but now what are
you gonna have right you're gonna have a
king Oni 7 bad development and defending
against White's checkmate attack for the
rest of the game so I kind of like it on
a practical level that way ye wants to
do this right he wants to show that I
want to get a win here but something
tells me that that's right in max seems
plans I think Maxime has gonna have a
harder time with these positional Knight
RS way he's been been successful with
rather than these super sharp lines okay
and we'll see
yeah he's he's won four in a row well
done for MBL we've got video Gujarati
back with me
it didn't take too much time did you eat
dinner I finished it quickly for you
watch it what you have what you have
some Indian dish you probably don't know
it's not okay what are you trying to say
you're saying that I don't enjoy Indian
cuisine I went with I took a nice Giri
to a nice Indian restaurant in Saint
Louis
yeah he is
he actually I'm gonna I'm gonna out him
right now he actually made me choose the
restaurant cuz he wanted to go to Indian
and his coach didn't and so he made me
take the fall so anyway classic Anish
you missed a poison point I was just
highlighting that way he goes away from
his g3 kind of positional night or for
the first time in the match he goes for
the main line he played the Bishop g5
poison pawn and we've got a full-piece
AK on the board yeah I said that I feel
like this is a bad sign vid and I'm
curious your thoughts because I know
that obviously way has lost his fourth
game in a row
but would you agree that going into the
sharpest lines here in the Sicilian the
poison pawn probably not something
Maxime is afraid of I think he's been
struggling more with the positional a
night off approach and I don't know that
this is a recipe for success four-way
eat and now start playing in the end of
the poisoned pawn what do you think of
the game yeah we're done I think run
yeah she ate I don't even know you go
did you see this I'm not so sure about
looks like black is just a piece tough
yeah and the d4 Knight is also pinned
yeah something went wrong boy yeah well
I would argue that it's just I don't
think this is what you want to do
against Maxine even with the positional
line now
working because I mean at this point I
would be taking Maxine if you start
diving into this sort of theory look at
the time as well right where you can use
to struggle on the clock and you believe
that it's like five and a half one and a
half and now it's going to be a lead for
India right Wow look at that move
opening up the East six square I love it
rook takes p7 he's going Queenie six
check next to take g8 but it still is
probably not enough maybe should be 727
we need 68 you can also just play King
d8 straight up here and run to c7 okay
he goes your route okay so this now the
bishop guards have fade and white is
running out of checks note each trying
to play 96 and he's like oh I forgot
it's pinned yeah yep this is about to be
six straight sorry five straight wins
for MBL I'm still stuck on six straight
I guess I'm prophesizing because it
could it could be six straight very soon
this game is in the books
where he falls and I don't know no right
crazy no it was such a good chance for
me I feel kind of bad for him it's such
a big lead he was getting good position
and then completed yeah he's he's gonna
have to write the ship here I mean at
this point even a draw has to be a
successful result I mean what would be
going in your head right now right you
were a yet a huge lead against against
somebody who's a favorite against you
and that's turning around now right I
mean what's going through your head
right now your lead has disappeared how
do you go for a draw do you just try to
stop the bleeding what do you what would
be your advice
thanks a lot get the draw just draw and
then you don't normalize little bit but
it's not so easy you know in place even
if you something want to toy not easy to
get it unless you're a nice PD classic
coming from a niche Gary's former second
no why why did you stop working with why
did you stop working with Annie so much
is it cuz you're gonna be better than
him soon or what many reasons I think he
yeah he chose everybody though so don't
feel so special
right he's kind of he's kind of
promiscuous when it comes to his
trolling I think yeah that's true
alright well if you're just joining us
this has been quite the amazing match we
have let's remind everybody who we have
here we actually have the number one
player from China and the number one
player from France it was a massive lead
for Wei Yi just an hour ago he was up
five and a half one and a half in this
match and even as the underdog in the
speech s championship format he was
showing that he was here to play
we know he's number three in China as we
said he is the number one junior in the
world the highest rated player on the
planet under the age of 21 but he's
going up against mvl today now Maxime of
course is known he's the number one
player in France he's actually currently
the highest rated rapid player in the
world and look at that damn good photo
right there that looks sexy right look
him look oh look at him feels picture
there vidit he looks scary like he looks
like a villain from a Marvel movie right
like yeah I'm talking about the picture
that's a great photo there but anyway
Maxime is uh is is an absolute monster
the beast of Lyon known as Lyon beast on
chest comm if you're just joining us
whether you are here via the twitch
frontpage or chest coms
homepage make sure you come to twitch.tv
slash just hit that follow button we
could be in for a thrilling one because
as we said we've now seen five wins in a
row from
seemed after falling behind big-time and
it could be the biggest comeback we've
ever had in a main SCC format okay so
before the three one you know goes ahead
I want to ask for your prediction again
okay
cuz I was are you just enjoying the fact
that I'm wrong a lot is that it I'm
trying to meet you would baby work a
little bit so I predicted it would be
four to six after the five minute for
way ye and ended up being five and a
half four and a half so I wasn't so far
off but you know III don't know at this
point I need to see where ye proved that
he's gonna stop the bleeding I'm gonna
guess that regardless of the score
maxime takes a two-game lead into bullet
that's what we're that's what I'm
feeling right now
do you yeah I would like to see you know
I mean like Levin suppose that would be
more fun to watch looking for that I'm
Rudy I'm rooting for to and it's been an
exciting one so I would I would not be
upset if we had a close match heading in
a bullet okay b7 is hanging and that's
key because it protects them then 94 or
probably be seven falls in the end of
those lines right yeah ninety-seven King
it you'd go for the night be okay he
goes forward 94 97 King h8 I think we're
probably gonna get aligned you're
talking about no he might dig one d5 was
that's the motion he does it take d5
first I guess that stops c7 now we get
the line that we have on the board where
East seven is still falling although now
not with check this Bishop d3 and 92 but
I think white will win the pawn on g7
tonight looking edge to night at four
takes a basic that's what I'm expecting
so something like Bishop d3 rugby 192
king h2 bishop a6 rookie 7 like this
yeah and I afford you wouldn't be sure
about five or somebody no you have to
take on that ah okay yeah yeah you take
a four first mission Matt five maybe
something like this but White has the
pass deep on right dirty dancing on the
D file
right we got da yeah my just better yeah
for sure
the Monsieur mistakes now oopsie salmon
you know what I want I want to sack the
exchange even if it doesn't work plate
d6 I'm kidding don't do that it might
just work
barely that sounded like you were like
the professor from a movie it might just
work love that it goes for it look at me
with the pawn sack that I didn't even
calculate but I'm still taking credit
for okay now you can play Brooke c7 now
you maybe want to save that guy yeah
he goes for d7 is coming again that the
slide continues I don't know what the
longest ever winning streak we've ever
had especially for someone who was at
one point trailing but we may be about
to get seven wins in a row we now have
it Maxime vache lagravis out of control
from what I've seen so far in 3 1
Maximus blink white well yeah I mean in
five the funny was he was all over the
board right but how do you explain quite
well I mean it really shows in the game
not just on the scorecard yep Maximus
has performed very well historically in
the 3-1 portion don't know if we have
those stats at some point but I know we
I know we tracked them he's performed
very well in this in this format and
he's often said it is his favorite time
control of the three disciplines so if
you're just getting here don't go
anywhere because we still have a lot of
chess ahead 38 minutes of blitz here
before 30 minutes of bullet to
ultimately decide who moves on into the
second round
okay now we've got this Carroll Khan so
Maxime going away from the knight or for
the first time today your thoughts on
that
why why changed uh probably my yeah Auto
Oh Noel in the twitch chat is correct
Nakamura won a lot of games in a row
I'm I like to yeah
my partner here has learned
ventriloquism that you were frozen there
for a second but you're back you're
you're you were talking and your mouth
wasn't moving but we've got you yeah I
think there was some like yeah but we
seem to be good so talk a little bit
about the structure here I think a lot
of members would maybe be confused about
why these double pawns are actually an
asset for black because they open the a
file but what's what's going to happen
here
I think black is doing quite well
tactically it's easy to play okay with
white I do not see a failure plan what
to do like 90 to g4 it doesn't look that
way it's like you just you know the
ninety six fish of Eastern put the rooks
on a five it's very easy to play with
black if you just take on e2 and go 96
I would have preferred yes so why does
any Trey why does he want the bishop is
it maybe to come to see - he's trying to
spy a four oh yeah there you go he does
it ultimately settles on the trade but
again Eckstein playing very quickly very
confidently so these doubled pawns as I
was saying everyone are an asset not
because the pawns themselves are super
pretty but because they open the a file
which makes whites life super hard for
the rest of the game as these trades
happen in the center and then they will
[Music]
the black hole black will play f6 right
would be and then he trades it probably
cause he wants nice c7 yeah he does it
and one of the things I was trying to
get to highlight as if the knight moves
from b5 then b5 itself can come from
black which takes advantage of the pin
so things like this are very common in
the structure right
initiative at least in practical terms
as thinking now to take on v5 and guru
create 13 yeah oops eh yeah now have six
and plaque looks like he's getting the
better the better endgame again that
both sides have BB pawns but it feels
like the v5 phone is an easier one to
target hmm now here comes four okay five
why did he trade on the a file
Gabriel gave more also good controlling
the fourth-ranked and preparing to swing
this just it feels like he has just
totally lost his mojo man he needs to
take his glasses off again and play
blindfolded like he was before he it is
it is dominating now it just that the
whole match is turned around it it it
feels the losing and the winning ones
right I've seen it now the thing he
needs to stop the bleeding that's why I
said make a draw you know somehow yeah
just stop a draw
let me make a draw stop the bleeding
gather yourself right
yeah don't stop the draw
don't stop believing either big journey
man you are right I know that
all right well way he's trying to hold
this end game would like a draw at this
point but I don't know that he's gonna
get it if you look at the time and the
fact that black is holding the cards you
look at these positions everyone black
and just play tickle and poke and poke
and look at that what wait you just
resigned you know we'll talk to him
about this afterward but he resigned
early that it um it right before you
joined me in a game right before you
joined me he resigned in a night off
where yes he was worse but it was a lot
like this right but
I think he has a match strategy of just
not letting himself lose a ton of time
to come back right if he feels like he's
gonna lose he's just gonna resign that's
what I thought yeah and again if I from
five and a half to one and I can imagine
he's totally reeling and it doesn't
change that fact that he's reeling but
again if this is your first ever SCC the
big thing everyone is is the time
ticking down you see that 30 minute
that's different than a normal chess
match where there's always motivation to
buckle down and play solid defense right
in this case you might you might defend
for three or four minutes and even if
you draw it in a match strategy right
vidit you're losing time on the total
game clock you're losing opportunities
to make a comeback so again that's what
makes this this format so interesting is
I know some of the players put a little
more thought into how to race against
the clock and I think way use resigning
because of that he wants opportunities
to come back but do something only one
game take one day I don't know just
please know this one game yeah you just
got to drop one time you're getting in
that ten game in a row realm for those
of you that follow the everyday and what
and give me the rule I think the only
match ever was a car Nakamura's match
against howie fun where he won ten in a
row at one point but I think that's the
only time it's ever happened in an SEC
question is playing now maybe rook c8
this looks okay for black this is the
best position he's had in some time
definitely I would go to Cup c8 and
consolidate probably Roxy a trophy for
28 is something we might see again this
time management I mean if I think young
he stay I agree he's just
double-checking overthinking and then
when it really matters he doesn't have
the time in the same position I would
have preferred that the hoop won't see
it because now we have some a7 some
tactics on the a7 pawn
yeah
95 wasn't good yeah 95 wasn't good
movies for King a7 and d6 cuz that's a
square that would win the bishop pair
back and so okay bb-8 is the only move
the guards both of them that makes sense
yeah maybe you'd love to play Bishop e5
is wide in a position to play a move as
aggressive as f4 or even Queen f4
actually I like coming over we have four
then you just think probably play 95 III
want to play queen of no okay Brooke c1
but that doesn't stop rook c8 which is
what I was wondering about how you would
deal with this yeah what's he doing here
what's he see he's clearly okay he's
obviously fine with the exchange now he
goes cleanup for interesting if Brooke
c1 he'll take b8 with check that's
that's actually kind of irritating and
if you take a four he'll probably take
c8 with check before recapturing but in
the end a six is still a target we're
gonna get that exact line so we'll keep
the analysis board up yep maybe I was
better than uh-huh because you just
allow the tempo yeah now if you play a
five I think Bishop g4 was coming so he
plays b5 a phone because we should these
things metric you should be fine uh-huh
you're so accurate you must be a really
good chess player look at that they
should be five and again despite the
Queen's being traded I think a lot of
players look at these games and feel
like it looks equal but no the targets
and the initiative or sometimes even
harder to deal with when you don't have
more pieces on the board you lack
counter play to take advantage of
something weak in your opponent's
position so white is white is holding
all the cards here this could be the one
six and a twenty seven and uh that would
be he may go for that anyway now I think
Bishop e5 he might trade on c7 anyway
but still white is holding the cards
right the bishop pair is gonna continue
to press sure
now he'll trade maybe eat by anyone
that's movies well he's trying not to
part with the bishop here wants to trade
a six for a four but what about 85
no like what e5 exam bishops ensuite
bishops the age it's gonna be Bishop c3
d4 Bishop d2 okay but now the king can
come all of the time yet the time again
favorite claim such a big difference and
you're still thinking I don't like this
time management yeah he's also only
playing with one eye so you gotta give
him credit
one night I kidding it was a joke for
how he looks on camera so it's hardly a
gun I mean okay no it's okay I'm just
making a joke but no I mean obviously
he's in a tough spot and so spotting
maxime and i is also ill-advised but
anyway maxime is just putting on a
clinic here of time management combined
with this working working it with no
diggity on both sides of the board this
is just rough okay now you can move the
bishop from d3 and try to put the king
there so you can get bishop before or
this way is because if you trade the
dark square bishop that gives white the
entry with the king right he would be
sure one be for it yeah that's gonna be
force the trade yeah if you waited then
this bishop it that's month looking b3
makes them f5 played i think we're gonna
get this idea of king b3 and Bishop
before soon here it comes
obviously we will try to play the Bishop
to e3 when that happens yep keep it on
the view
but then the king will run back yeah
that's actually getting harder vaccine
is pushed a little too far maybe he'll
settle yeah you think so yeah okay all
right well you were right we have peace
in the land and I'm expecting Bishop d2
by way you not sure why he's thinking
okay I guess he considered you know what
he was considering there was maybe
Bishop d6 but made the right call
because if trade trade king before
guards king c5 and that if d4 but then
black has d4 maybe King d5 nobody
thinking you have a chief or hangs in
those lines with Bishop of three right
yeah but we think the line the way you
was considering was Bishop d6 and if
takes tags King before his Keon and now
d4 opens up the bishop and maybe in
country King C for Bishop f3 cuz the
bishop was blocked was what I was saying
take c4 takes here we get our own pawn
but in the end I guess White's but I
don't know I mean look at this like if
you go for this line Vinit with like
Bishop c4 a 6 I get king c7 anyway no I
guess king c5 and the bishop moves in a7
okay I was just kidding no but that was
an instructive line right and that might
have been something he was looking at at
the last second and made the decision to
take the draw instead what is going on
here there's a queen on e8 and okay back
to the Batcave let's see what happened
in the opening to the Batcave yeah we've
got another poisoned pawn maxime not
afraid of it again I just don't like the
trend for wayy to commit to this line
just given that he was getting better
advantages in the more positional night
or maybe he felt like maxime had figured
it out but as crazy as this all looks
this is actually all theory and you know
white sacrifices the Queen just to win
it right back in the end though black is
playing with the bishop pair
and usually just totally settled here so
not a huge opening win maybe you can
take the exchange and then you should be
okay white eye I would have prefered we
should be people instead of 90 on move
20 they just just waited move 22 Bishop
d3 get developed okay I don't know black
is getting compensation for the exchange
that's for sure positions open up again
this is this is right in MBL's
wheelhouse black you know what's the
best way to play and just when I see it
and give an exchange then go for the
trough yeah well I guess we didn't take
a moment to appreciate that way II just
got on the board for the first time in
an hour and a half if you're just
joining us Maxine Bosh a the Grove
comeback got to seven straight victories
at one point in this match that's right
way II was up five and a half to one and
a half so oMG xur snaps right and maxime
had won seven games in a row before that
last draw so I think from a practical
point of view at least where he's got to
be happy about that right he didn't lose
again that it yeah yeah definitely but
three points lead you know I'm kind of
worried yet for a maybe I don't think
it's easy to recover that I predict and
we are going to take this yeah and these
and these bish this is a great example
of the two bishops how well they work
with the rook the rooks and the night
even though white is up the exchange dr.
evil fingers this is clearly material
that favors black in fact white almost
has mating nets to worry about right h5
and H for could be coming oh maybe this
NB and but I was talking about the
overall match that I think we will win
now
yeah looking at this wouldn't depend
yeah
well yeah he's obviously weathered the
storm
h5 is it possible to play h5 and then
droop you think he's gonna settle on the
draw again apparently why not I didn't
say anything time continues to tick away
we have 20 minutes left here in the
three-minute portion so embedded link
piped in p1 very consistent no big
mistakes very solid yeah he's uh he's
found himself the plane I don't yep
daughter playing I Dorf it's a Sicilian
battle today apparently a theoretical
Sicilian lesson but we all signed up for
my dispositional night or fight sorry
what yeah now I think they go castles a5
Bishop v6 and some kind of us no
positional in okay
yeah we'll see if MBL can give us a
lesson on how to play the night off his
white normally he's playing these
positions as black but the bishop comes
to f3 why would love night f 193 and
then sink a pony permanently here on the
d5 square so giving us something to look
forward to here in terms of what we'll
learn about how he plays the night or
but speaking of looking forward to
things minute let's remind everybody of
our schedule because tomorrow we have
Nepal Miyagi vs. Danielle Ian that is
the four seed versus the 13 seed in our
speed chess championship epic event this
year that starts at 7:00 a.m. Pacific
time so tune in for that
our next match after that is on the six
do two versus your boy uh nice giri
although i think you and i would both
agree that dude is probably a favorite
in that match over an ish no III loyal
and okay fine I'll say I'll say do too
just so I can get whatever trolling
comes from an itch later and then we
take a break during the World Cup and
before Russian on Russian action
probably the r-rated kind and our timmy
of versus grishnak I can't promise what
happens on that show but I think you
should tune in on the 29th and then we
have our own Ian versus firoozeh sorry
what that's going to be the most epic
match it seriously is right I mean our
team of is like I always think of him as
like a young Grichuk the guy is so
talented
in blitz I don't know what he's capable
of a lot of people look at him as a dark
horse on the right side of the bracket
to may be upset Sasha and run one leg do
nothing last year yeah apparently Siri
thought that Sasha means Siri hey Siri
hey Siri well yon kristef Duda beat a
nice giri on Friday know who will win
the match of due to vs. giri on Friday
you can be wrong all night as long as
it's in that accent I'll turn it off now
what did I sign no I don't know man
I just thought all right what's
happening here we have our positional
goal the night reaches d5 yeah it just
looks good for white and this is this is
kind of a structure that wayy has been
trying to play against nvl all match or
at least earlier in the five-minute
portion this is the more positional
approach for the night or if you have
this four on three over here on the
kingside and in compensation black gets
the potential for a pawn storm over here
f-4e 4g4 it's all on the agenda but
White's positionally about it I would
think
Oh efore I don't like evil sorry what
can you alright what do you think nail I
[Music]
don't like to move in for you don't like
the movie for while yeah yeah I mean the
night comes on g4 that's why I thought
black should go g6 in g7 and because
it's not only because it's kind of a
minus 94 yeah
hey come on let it go here a good
position it's got a six coming yeah 96
white is clearly better no
and look at the time again nothing no
it's a huge probably thing really these
they know he gave a look over his
shoulder like I thought he was about to
resign just kind of frustrated making
sure nobody's watching his debacle in
that hotel room and a deed he throws in
the towel Wow I mean this has just
become an MDL clinic here the three one
portion is where he does well
historically really have helped lessen
substitutions when you know you had such
a good lead and then you lose game of
the game it's very tough but it does
like logic yeah again he had a huge lead
everything's falling apart I think one
of the bad Sciences even though the lead
fell apart he was getting good positions
on the white side of those night Orff's
do you agree at least the h3 and g3
lines he was playing yeah he was and
actually like the type of question he's
playing down I thought he would go for
impact then so avoid the rest you know
and just hold on to the lead got it if
you are going with a big lead in 5-1 it
would have been much easier to play the
rest of the match but the last three
games 3d took its toll because now you
can see that yes light initiative
nothing much but it's very healthy
position maybe something of this sort
he should have a factor in hindsight
yeah I just the fact that he's mixing it
up now and not finding answers is just a
bad sign sometimes when these guys
prepare the openings for the match it
goes so well they never have to switch
but if they start switching and not
finding any improvements not a bad not a
not a good sign of the future why not
apparently heading into this match Wei
Yi said he thought his chances were less
than 1% to win so maybe it's a
confidence issue in some ways last
nothing yeah
it's such a good position down boy very
comfortable this book see one final is
Hagen but I don't like that yeah Justin
free pawn is a good start
agreed you know I'm surprised that my
accent isn't being a problem for you
usually when I speak half of the people
don't understand I speak many accessing
not I don't speak many languages but I
speak many accents so it's one of my one
of my specialties so no no trouble here
and you at all buddy you maniac how do I
speak many accents it's a skill I'll
teach you it later all right Brooke c1
he defends his pawn what are the options
with like 10 second not like after
thinking for a minute right
that's know one thing I don't like yeah
the time management has been has been
poor so no Bishop f4 flick with me yeah
I mean he's taking this 10 seconds
process to me is I think the confidence
because you when you lose so many games
yep you would like check recheck
everything even the simple position
right would not have happened early and
maybe it doesn't happen in even in a
traditional tournament where you have a
rest day you have time to kind of gather
yourself when you have so many games
back to back to back here you know the
emotional hangover is real and it's easy
for us to say things like how to improve
but while they're playing it's just hard
to make those adjustments right but I'm
just saying what I feel objectivity
should grab right well he's better here
I mean maybe we'll get a victory here
for way you for the first time and you
need needs this big time if you're just
joining us way he has not won in almost
an
in 45 minutes it's been a while home
okay so windy for right huh tell you
quickly right there you go
eggs and eggs on D for decency one and
go keep do is probably what MB yeah b7
falls in the end of the wine but they do
yeah it's gonna come down to the deep on
the tea point it does no doubt but can
you win is the person mm-hm
d5 threatens Bishop c6 though that's
okay now there's no g7 and Bishop h6
that was f6 was kind of surprising
what about rook e7 no he doesn't go for
it wonder if the dark scores were a
problem and you may be G by mu u 5g
fives coming for a Maxine for sure
agreed yeah these pawns are weaknesses
but all work really wants us to get the
King in the game just wouldn't be yeah
blockade even okay but there's still the
option of trading and playing rookie 7
no no okay 154 now you can put the rock
on a 1 or blemish of a 7 but then there
is room key to he has to move faster and
yeah he doesn't have a chance to just
double checking which many lines yeah
one of these moves
I know when you lose 7 but practically I
think in builders that way okay there's
there's this Bishop g6 but it does
nothing that King has safety and you
can't guard d6 now
unless you have rook 8:1 and you can't
learn yeah yeah he finds from game one
but but what's the follow-up rook b1
okay
tickle tickle me elbow very good yeah
that's a great move now the D pawn will
fall and even the beginning is a drone
that right trade king of seven that King
comes to e6 D cha yep draw you should
just know we're going to see a thing
right
Indonesian violin yeah I think he
probably will he's been good about match
strategy all day
you know it doesn't even diamond door
for the dog yeah he's afraid to go click
the draw button but he has not offered a
draw we see the draw emotes coming out
in the chest calm chat they're like yeah
I think just play tickle here offer a
draw this thing full cup way by
repeating moves yeah agent J Elvis here
earlier when MV L was way down and now
you come back and different story we
have an epic comeback on on the docket
here today apparently we didn't know but
MV elbows down five and a half one and a
half now leads it 11 to 7 just a
complete turnaround four games down now
four games up
shoutout to down to narrowed its key
hanging out and the twitch chat go to
twitch.tv slash whatever his channel is
doctor narrowed it's gotta you know
Danya I don't think anybody has changed
their channel name more than you like in
the history of twitch not just like like
chess so shout out to you buddy but
anyway give him a follow
there you go GM narrowed its key finally
deciding on a brand good for you buddy I
think Donna's gonna be doing some
commentary for us pretty soon here
trying to work him in so unless you mean
he's quite entertaining yeah
Danya narrow disc you go to his channel
give him a follow if you're into strong
grandmasters who play chess good
kind of like going to the school for
kids who read don't read good that's
where I went
so come on that's a Zoolander reference
bro have you seen Zoolander no we're
gonna have to fly you out and have some
pop culture video so I'm gonna I'm gonna
show you all the movies I need you to
see for future working together I've had
this conversation with my colleagues and
they come to the conclusion that I
didn't have a childhood that's the
reason I don't know any of this so is
that true did you not have a childhood
or you like Benjamin Button and I can
tell you have not seen like Harry Potter
the rest I mean the things which
everyone has seen yeah you can make your
assumptions okay well if you can ever
get out of that beehive if you maybe you
could see some movies so that the
b-movie which stars Jerry Seinfeld and
why are the flow was disappearing in the
meadow I'm a bee and you don't know
Jerry Seinfeld I know sign for that see
miss you're a big fan okay that's it I
didn't you just won me back into your
heart with that bro
Seinfeld great show all right that's a
great outpost square on d3 but will you
keep it probably not I assume 91 is
coming soon now if you want to beat the
d3 yeah undermine the protection I like
that right I like how you think
yeah it's if you put a knight on d3
always use protection but if that
disappears now you got to rid yourself
with the outpost square and actually
White is gonna be just fine
you've got the big Center and and you're
happy to use it isn't that lucky but
though you really think so yeah you're
the Grand Master so I guess I gotta
trust you but I like white I mean it's
probably level but you know I thought so
okay why do you why do you think black
is why do you think luck is better so
you've got the charm wasn't but now
thank buddy right so you've got the
two-on-one that's what I thought I was
assuming I was highlighting that that
but I look at the centrally placed night
and the fact that this Bishop can't
really join the fray cause a d4 and I
just it's hard for me to think that
white is not in control even though I
mean absolutely fine is that I would
prefer to play black that's what I mean
got it
I should probably know 95 maybe 45
wonder I love it
you're reading my mind I highlighted it
right as he did it
II 45 if we're also just sitting on the
square holds d5 and denies you your
plane of 95 so that's nice
rook c2 to defend the rook that on pins
the night so now you can move it without
the rook falling on c1 I like it
we got to give credit where credit's due
the time advantage is not as big for MV
l pre as it was previously wayy has fed
up a little bit
unfortunately he's no you I was gonna
say unfortunately it's coming with a
blunder might be seven in the game's
over
I don't know why I was right but I just
knew white was better and just to
highlight why that night couldn't be
taken everyone let me just show you the
night was poisoned due to the fact that
the Queen had to guard the rook and
moving moving the Queen would have
allowed Queen takes the a check so
Knight takes b7 was a blunder that way
you missed and the game goes from
debatably better between me and vidit in
terms of who we like to white just
winning on the spot and there you have
it we have another game in the books a
five game lead now for Maxine Bosh a
magrav he's pretty good it's just they
even don't watch you know it's on full
tilt but remember there's still
something on the line in every game
let's remind you the daily question I
want to get your thoughts on this video
so obviously in this be Chess
Championship format the prize money is
both guaranteed and then
split by wind percentage so if this is
your first time watching it every game
still matters even if you're gonna lose
the match and it can matter to the tune
of 20 to 30 bucks and sometimes as high
as a couple hundred dollars depending on
all the matches we've done but one thing
we've talked about is whether drawers
should even count toward the total score
if we if we could consider some way that
drawers maybe add to the pot so that the
neck decisive game is worth even more
not just in terms of the match score but
also the cash money homie I know you're
a big fan of making it rain in the club
are you a big fan of the Cash Money idea
of rolling drawers so let's say a draw
doesn't count toward the total score but
it doubles the prize money for like the
next decisive game in an SCC format
would you like this idea so and I'm not
getting so let's say they draw this game
instead of the score changing from
eleven half to seven and a half the
score stays eleven seven but but the
next game is now worth double the prize
money if it was if it was split by one
percentage if they draw again then it
then the next game is worth triple the
prize money and you just keep adding up
the score doesn't change draws don't
count until you get decisive games oh no
no I mean you can do it I don't know the
draws are a problem in our format
honestly I think that draws are
sometimes very excited and well play
very exciting and we'll plate and it's
not like we have a problem with
classical preparation making sure that
nobody blunders but it's just something
we've considered whether we could find a
way to make the scoring even more
decisive but you're not into this I'm
just playing
so I usually don't have any problem with
drawing right is that a requirement to
remain his friend because he gets upset
when I don't score fifty percent yeah
that makes sense actually well we'll get
the draw masters you think something
went wrong right I'm used okay well I
mean
jokes aside and each giri is number four
in the world for a reason obviously a
very solid and strong chess player but
anyway you can let us know your thoughts
on our daily question use the hashtag
speed chess we showed you the image
earlier and if you want you can hold for
hover your mouse over the twitch player
you will see a little button that's a
vote extension click it cast your vote
and and let us know your thoughts only
50 seconds remain here vidit this will
officially I'm going to call it gonna be
our last three 1-game I don't think
we're gonna see a blunder in the next 40
seconds so quite well I think we had
played this game and snip OH in
paragraph three okay yeah yeah poor
suffering but right now immunised really
quite wet
big king of snakes rookie one yeah it's
a little bit tricky no yeah it is rooty
seven right now yeah I like that move
you should play it fast
rookie seven you want to bring the other
rook in potentially but how do you how
do you get at the King on h6 that's the
problem
not easy at all right maybe we'll get
seven now you can even rotate severai
like this yeah okay now I think your
rook b2 is six ideas 9450 finite aha
maybe you got fork on the brain there I
love it okay he plays rook b2 it seems
the straightforward idea both a to and
c2 will fall but just a clinic right now
maxime vache the graph has not lost a
game what no gate what's happening yeah
Brooke AJ and white is stuck
or Rock g7 because if you move the
bishop you're not even threatening rook
h8 the rook just goes right back this is
just painful painful for Wei Yi and like
I was saying it Maxime we talked about
why you're not winning that it Maxime
hasn't lost a game in about two hours so
yeah well okay right now ye thinking not
quite sure how to deal with the rook on
the second-ranked that's about to get
loose ninety to check he goes ninety
four he wants g3 first and then then I
can come to f5 and target h4 that's his
idea and let's say emulate this 3:1
section very good yeah
high quality stuff and no no medium one
time then I will get h4 and it's too
late for way he would love to already
have the bishop on g8 and thread and
checkmate but not gonna happen
and okay black is gonna bring the knight
to d4 I think and then and then take on
either c2 or b3 either way he'll end up
with two passed pawns versus whatever
one remains and black will be easily
winning and we will be headed into the
one-minute portion here because this has
been this has been just this is a
portion that way you would like to
forget right okay I guess I guess I
spoke too soon well you found a way to
swindle the draw he did actually take
what the c1 yeah king of two was a good
move he gets the King out so that he can
take with the C pawn note that if the
King was on the second rank the pawn is
pinned but okay still even with holding
this game he heads into the fastest set
down five games that's a tough order
tall task for anyone to overcome against
Maxine
the Grove but we'll see if the Chinese
is up for it here at Grand Master Wei Yi
he's gonna do what he can in the bullet
portion do what he did against ali reza
firoozeh which was surprised some people
that it you're sticking with us for the
bullet right what had happened well we
beat Ali Reza firoozeh in I think of the
president and the bullet portion
firoozeh one I think but it wasn't a
landslide right obviously so we're gonna
be right back here in just a moment with
more speeches championship action don't
go anywhere
bullet coming right up
[Music]
and we are back here with chest coms
second match of the 2019 speeches
championship with me here the amazing
video Gujarati filling in here today at
the last moment and bring in the a game
a plus commentary and well we already
set the tone right we know that this is
way ease here to come back but it's been
all day all MBL ever since he started
this comeback if you're just joining us
Maxine was down five and a half one and
a half in this match
he was down four games he's now up by
five so it has been quite the turnaround
but will bullet bring better fortune
let's find out let's do it
the games are beginning and we have the
fastest time control of the day under
way I know you're so you're not a huge
bullet guy yourself
you wish you were though right I play
quite decently but I feel I enjoy two
plus one or five plus one more right and
usually like ten seconds plus one and I
love that yeah why is that
it's so much fun I mean it you should
you should try so it's ten seconds to
start plus one so it's like hyper bullet
with an increment yeah and it's not okay
very cool all right well we've got a
caro-kann two knights the first time
that we're yi has ventured away from a
Sicilian I think it's been a lot of
Sicilians today and I come into this
line for black in my DVD of oh yeah yeah
and the conclusion that time I thought
it was okay but later on I found out
that what is better okay something like
that yeah well we saw we saw this this
line played at the sync folk up by
Maxime right this was his game versus a
horrible thing so just like just between
yeah oh my gosh what a way for the
landslide to continue
I'm gonna back up real quick on the
analysis board just to show how that one
ended and that was crazy so in this
position here the move castles is just a
blunder after Queen f2 black needs to
deal with the coming threat of a4 and
Bishop takes d4 black plays the
instinctive castles I think when you see
the battery on f7 you get worried you
want to get the King out of the middle
but then a4 and Bishop takes d4 and the
Queen is trap before you know it
crazy trades and stuff here yeah just
when I plug in my DVD black noses into
Moses
yeah hey that'll teach you from plugging
your own stuff right well so but as I
was saying that line was actually played
at the sink field Cup between Maxine
vache magrav and Cara Nakamura not
obviously Hikaru didn't butter his queen
but that same line was also played by
black there so you're I'm sure your DVD
is solid people should check it out
and now ambien has different my DVD yeah
come on in VO play the caro-kann
courtesy of video Gujarati at some point
and now the bird uplink are opened yeah
that's funny this thing they're just
mirroring each other
yep okay well white is uh I don't know I
think a little bit better here I know
we're trying to defend the Carroll
Collider
why does Brenda I don't know cuz I like
the bishop on e5 and I'm hitting g7 I
don't know I like the material
I mean objectively white should be okay
but I think if you consolidate it's a
healthy okay Bishop f6 that's actually
that's a serious problem we did was a
very nice yeah very sneaky maneuver now
he's gonna win d4 and h4 something tells
me that we're about to witness an MV L
run away here because at this point he's
up six games and the bullet portion
something he's typically known for being
one of the world's elite so he's a
really good and bullet
I mean he doesn't play online as often
as guys like Hikaru Nakamura or oli Reza
firoozeh but I would say that for a guy
of his caliber right in the 2800 realm
he's definitely one of the best ball
players for sure he did oh yeah he did
he messed it up and all of a sudden here
comes two pastors on the queenside they
should be forced met by Bishop h3 I
think or Bishop c6 but then do too and
then takes on ceasing okay yeah bishop
is better you threaten of seventh now
probably a four first yeah so that the
pawn can remain protected but it should
be good with the bishop its bishop on a
stay locked out yeah
and f5 next f5 will keep the bishop out
and then you can play for a three or run
the King up who wants checkmate right
who wants dinner King comes to g3 Oh
King gets for now f3 and came g3 are
both possible but f3 even stronger the
bishop is hanging oh sure he's thinking
about I thought it was thing about maybe
came g3 but no unnecessary
no to g7 Bishop chief for days excellent
youthful and because these two passed
pawns are super good and now b7 that's a
problem I think kinga 3 was a blunder
yeah mech seemed kind of shakes his head
and just resigned that that game turned
around fast yeah cheap ones and he
hadn't exchanged Queens yeah but okay
wait you just won his first game in more
than two hours right
you know what would be fun to watch I
mean I I'm good I like mvl but it would
be more fun to watch it may even like a
couple of games yeah and then it will be
more interesting I remember when your
three inch down against fish oh yeah the
last three or something like this it was
epic Jay came back and tied it that was
still one of the most exciting matches
we've ever had for
but okay way he gets his thing like that
yeah I'm with you
let's do it come back come back come on
come on crowd you can chant right show
us your wayi emos if you're a subscriber
to the twitch channel twitch.tv slash
chess I don't know what kind of comeback
email we have in the chest comm chat but
I'm sure you can think of something like
a unicorn that's like a comeback so
because by the way unicorns are making
comebacks I mean in general the unicorns
are very popular like unicorn shirts
uniform backpacks that kind of stuff so
as you know I'm not that's okay not so
good either okay it's wrote xh5 coming
here that's what I want
when decent is a good move maybe Bishop
III know you're threatening to take on
f5 and go G for next ah okay I like that
you take f5 can't take with the pawn
because the bishop falls and if you take
with a piece then g4 forking well why
does your nowadays Queen f7 died
yeah MV o is tricky here Queen D AIT's
not easy for it or does it
okay but this finds a way to win the
pawn back if you're Maxime and keep a
very good knight on d5 you can even
trade on d4 and then find a way to
Castle long White's in great shape
kingi to look at that opening up the
Queen h1 battery I love it you know I'd
really love is for him to put his King
on d3 I put the Queen there wrong piece
magazine look at the time even my liking
yeah it's fantastic rook h1 hitting h7 g
4 closing things up on the lights worse
97 97 was just crushing on the spot but
maxime he gets away with the blunder
just rub against my back rook comes to
f5 Bob's your uncle you lose on the
clock losing on the board oh man this is
just this has been quite the turnaround
well we were wondering what it would
take for Maxime to get his groove back
right some luck and some luck and some
accidents kids and a lot of skill yeah
97 now you bring it to f5 threatens rook
h7 okay
taking these six also does the trick
it's so enjoyable is that that sounded a
little bit like you know sadistic yeah
I'm okay with it I'm kind of into it but
I'm just letting you know that that
sounded a little sadistic rook d6
speaking of sadistic Maxime is about to
take a six-game lead once again oh man
you should just resign nobody you yeah I
think at this one he kind of knows it's
over and he's almost probably not even
emotionally present right now it's like
Shaun unshunned right they doesn't want
to talk about image three oh yeah yeah
that was crazy
although Mahmoud yarv started playing
better with the bad openings look at
this portion so yeah this is not chess
you would advise people to go for but
look at Lissa's Maxime turning it into a
huge center and just a an ideal position
even Knight takes before as a potica he
goes for it because the pawn is pinned
you should play cool Bishop a5 do it
little one yeah it's about to happen
Bishop at five oh it goes B should be
six why not Bishop a5 I don't see why I
don't get to know
no you still I think he just missed
before five
okay this move threatens d4 but Bishop
of five was threatening but not only
Knight see to everyone but also 93
winning the Queen so was a was a w and
maybe Maxime loses this one now because
of it that night is still under attack
all right he gets it back to c6 no so
sorry I've lost games worse than this
but yeah yeah I should be hard to lose
this with black here comes the other
rook to c8 and that's gonna be a problem
I would play night since the exact Union
because Roxy queen is slightly
annoying there you go and you can I
don't be one it's very pleasant yeah
that's a problem that's a big problem so
he's gonna try to fix that development
problem by playing a four but black hole
trait Queens and then win the a four
pawn in the process a for blacks hungry
what do you think of bullets I mean
right now I think he's I think he's
doing what we expect I mean MBL is one
of the toughest characters here so I
think it's I think it's hard to expect
him to make a comeback if you guys think
overall what I think of way use
performance in bullet I think he's
consistently surprised people by how
good he's been throughout the juniors
features championship but right now he's
just I don't know he's doing what I
would expect King takes d4 would have a
lot of for Connie too but I expect
Maxime to dominate this portion much
like he did the three one gosh if you're
just joining us look at that score
Maxime one eight to two in the in the
3-1 portion well that's a huge that's a
huge that's a huge disparity there okay
well you gets the rook to be six
oh no he does and he missed this all the
night repeats with it just it's all just
falling apart it's it's due once
no I thought will take c6 worked as well
because the work will go to b6 but yeah
this check it was Czech I always forget
those checks you know well talk to the
players in the interview what are we
gonna ask him that it I mean surely we
should ask Maxime how he dealt with
being down five and a half one and a
half how he kept himself calm and you
know sure then maybe ask me what he
thinks he would have done better yet to
not to not to not lose the lead and
experience of this yes yep then we'll
dive into the obviously much more
important questions the snacks of choice
for Maxime today did you see the B step
did he just blunder the piece yes lol
we've got a chess comm lol emote a loli
mode showing showing me at my fattest
there you go enjoy that your sin is left
actually the way how much time is left
of the galette section we have like 16
minutes can happen yeah I don't happen
before expected a but how do you find a
way to get an attack here you'd love to
remove that knife for me three and slip
the Queen over here but you got to deal
with your pieces first and look at
Maxime he's getting he's getting a lot
of counterplay down a piece or not
whether king of it so clean getting in
trouble but no way to trap it probably
95 at some point here is what the doctor
ordered but the problem is you don't
really want to trade any pieces this way
preparing it now now 95 will come
because if you take we take what Chuck
simply should be 5 okay but watch out
watch out actually this is if this if
this game goes Mac seems way this would
be the the icing on the cake no more if
it will be 7 where's the mate
queen h7 is now ok he takes a three
everything's changing this kind of depth
that bad technique for sure if you play
queen g2 you can even try to get the
chief file if you're Maxime I'm
surprised you didn't go for that
ok now it's no it's so now it should be
easy for what you famous last words
should be easy oh my gosh least we got a
smile there from Wei Yi he's like well
if I can't win those games I might not
win it all right
that's I'm pretty sure what that that's
what that smile meant I mean it sure is
but you know it's not gonna be painful
to watch all of our upcoming events
especially because some of them have you
competing we've got the speeches chance
yeah ok as you can see that's underway
we've got the protest League qualifier
for the 2020 season on September 28th
then we've got the feed a chest calm
greens Swiss that's where video Gujarati
and many others will be trying for a
spot in the candidates tournament which
ultimately decides the next challenger
to the World Chess Championship so the
chess comvita grand swiss is a big deal
make sure you've got your October free
and then the Fischer random World Chess
Championship we should probably also add
the fishing random quarterfinals October
through six since that's when you'll be
playing video and maybe you'll be
playing in Norway as well but that's our
that's our big events right there and
also reminder let's bring it up right
here because we still got vetted October
four through six Wow MBL wins another
game this is this is getting out of
control but coming up soon we have eight
of our nine players remaining we will
decide three of them who will move on to
play in the World Chess Championship in
Oslo where they will be joined by the
unofficial reigning Fisher random World
Chess Champion that's Magnus Carlsen so
then I'm seeing it now that's just crazy
that's not so nice of mixing well you
know sometimes happens g4g v g6 I mean
frankly this looks like a new game that
I kind of like White's position it takes
with the King on DT that's unnecessary
not really because I think these guys
know that they're you know streaks like
this happen and no that's what I'm
saying I don't know that I would be I
mean again maybe it's just because I'm
used to being abused on camera all the
time I don't know I mean if you're
asking me personally like I wouldn't be
offended but you know I think I think
sometimes when it rains it pours and we
see that right at the high levels even
you know somebody has to get last place
and if you're not on Form against a
really strong player like mvl bleep
happens right isn't that why they
invented the bumper sticker bleep
happens oh my gosh five and he's forking
him on e7 it's out of control out of
control right now
95 yeah just still can't take with the
Queen everyone we had a fork on e7 this
is just nasty you have to predict
Ambulance next opening okay I'm gonna
say f6 King f7
well I think g5 would like lazy 4G fine
okay I think I'm taking f7 is next here
we go you go right back Adam I love it
let's get some g4 double X clam there
you go
well stick around in ten minutes we're
gonna have the players join us for
interviews and it's always interesting
to hear these players insights
regardless of the results obviously this
one seems to be in the bag and some of
our first round matchups are fun for
different reasons even if they aren't as
close sometimes they become clinics with
one player flexing in this case Maxime
is uh he's a boss so are you playing in
the protest league this year yes and
bling for the chimney cheetahs ah the
new oh that's right and who's busy
playing for he played last year for
Mumbai is he playing again I have no
idea I thought you should be you should
know that no Danny I'm supposed to I
don't I don't pay attention anyway I
think that she's playing but I don't
remember for who but the protest League
were the best players in the world
compete for it we must just kid he's
very involved with chess good and I do
talk to him about that we talked about
that in st. Louis and he's he's been an
awesome ambassador chess kid is already
growing in India if you didn't know
chess kid calm it's where all the cool
kids play so go check it out
rook h4 okay it looks like way he's
about to strike I'm calling it away you
victory in this game actually might be a
little premature but I'm thinking he
gets a win now the only thing which is
keeping me interested in opening choices
in there okay that's where you gets a
victory at W Westside W
Viji for every G for gets an emote just
like an angel gets its wings who is
laughing to himself and I tell them
don't bring your rook out first in front
of the pawns and hey luckily they don't
ever watch any of these shows so hey
somebody stole my g4 emote that was my
idea who stole that you can make emotes
yeah I didn't know that yeah blitz
stream took it class oh wait no he
deserves him more than me because he's a
Grob guy he legit plays g4 so okay all
right you win Kevin you get to have it
by the way speaking of which Kevin is
covering this this event this match at
our French channel so for all of
Maxine's fans will be very happy that he
weathered the storm and made a comeback
Kevin boardy notice blitz stream I just
recommend on twitch it said that I need
to open my mind up ya know what did me
he's open his mind a bit I don't know
they it could just be a direct reference
to you needing to watch the matrix again
I'm trying to frame your mind I love
when I see their come in so you know and
they troll you in fact we should remind
people they can't follow you on twitter
you're not a regular streamer as much as
we'd like you to be you're busy but you
know we we work with vidit as much as we
can and maybe maybe this will be a
little bit of motivating but you know
what you guys the 2019 calendar makes it
so it's hard for me to to push anybody
to stream I'm kind of like just rest
buddy just rest just stay fresh you know
but go to twitch.tv slash video chest to
follow his channel would you watch if I
scream
of course I'll watch I'll subscribe to
your channel and I think a lot of other
people in the chat would too I think
you'd have some subscribers for sure
many kinds and the first opening will be
cheap for what if I Street yeah
if you streams are calling it right now
the all right the route continues here
we've got about five minutes left before
the interviews will commence we'll see
what the players think right now I think
Maxime is having a good time are we
gonna get all chief or for the rest of
the day at this point I'd be
disappointed if we had anything but
chief or oh we should do that yeah we
should do a team chess battle I mean I
think you and anis might be better than
me and Robert in some ways but in some
ways maybe not so much you know I would
like that
but probably by my own teammate yeah
he's not a very he's not a very easy guy
to get along with I know this everybody
knows that no chief for g5 yeah it's fun
more g-force you know let's do it let's
do a team chess battle even if yeah yeah
so you'll have a teammate there well
we'll find it we'll find a team that can
throw down with you guys honestly that's
a really strong team that it Gujarati
and a nice giri so we'll try to you
should sort of this challenge do name
one tweet oh I will I will I think me
and Robert could take you guys though
because me and Robert have this
chemistry that just brings out the best
in him and the worst in me all the time
and that ends up making a really good
combination for shows or we could do it
where we'll have like me and you versus
Robert and Aneesh and we know that the
niche would love to be on Roberts team
so many exciting combinations yeah we
can do like you know they have like wife
swap we can do partner swap we can just
swap team mates
right right well just well swap and
they'll be a ruled that Danny gets to
choose any position he wants at any time
I just choose the position I once which
teammates like I like this game we're
coming up with here yeah team chess
battle is coming up Nick I know you're
listening we got to make that happen
let's make that happen let's let's talk
to Annie Shaw I'll ping him on skype
right now and we'll get fitted we'll get
better to help me convince him I think
he will have conditions he's probably
watching the show he has nothing better
he acts like he's busy and then he
comments on all the shows he's watching
you should have extra points for
drooling and we'll have we'll make like
a fan prize where the the crowd the
twitch chat can donate for the best
trash talker throughout the day I love
ya that's just very good chances to win
that though I mean I'm like 1,600 when
it comes to that in terms of trash
talking yes Wow I don't know if that's
true you've held your own today I think
just trashing a niche doesn't seem to be
a problem for you these will make it so
you're not on his team for fun then it's
kind of sad that we stopped watching the
games I know I don't know what's going
on it's been all G for all day they're
calling each other's bluff right now
who's gonna make the first good move
okay be five look at this Willie's laugh
at ovios laughing we use raising him
smothered mate I think three points to
be
being a good sport and going along with
this you know I would not be able to do
that what you did well it's hard but I
think he also considered himself an
underdog right so even though he was
winning and he would have liked it to
stay that way I guess in the end it
didn't necessarily change the way he
thought the match was gonna go I mean he
I guess he considered Maxime to be the
heavy favorite so Joe slim and the chess
TV chat wants to know where you can find
the games we have news articles of
course where you can see summaries but
if you look up anyone's username or
profile on chess calm like literally
just click the user name right now lyon
beast then you go to their profile you
can see any game anyone has ever played
on chess comso easiest thing to do is to
just go to someone's profile and look at
their history if you're looking for
games in some of the more recent matches
protip for everybody there we've got 50
seconds I think officially this will
actually I can't say official via our
last game could be anything I have no
idea what's happening next I think it's
the last game do you think so Queen d3
now you're threatening Queen h3 and
Queen g3 to get the Queen's off the
board okay mate yourself oh I wanted him
to made himself with rook d1 come on
where you win the last game come on get
him get him Wei Yi openly rooting for
Wei Yi right now rook T to crush him get
him we need to be 23 darnit Maxime oh
man Queen d6 hitting the f8 rook okay I
love it you threatened made
- no you don't have much time move okay
something tells me that I'm not gonna
get the victory I wanted four-way ye
okay tell me you second so no time for
anybody in way ye goes down on the clock
man and we have a final score in the
books 21 to 10 after an hour in this
match where the score was five and a
half one and a half way ye led I would
if you had told if you had told anybody
that this would be the final score you
would have been slapped silly right
called crazy and surely don't go
anywhere
what I didn't expect that it would be
such a big difference and especially in
the weight started well don't go
anywhere we're gonna be joined by the
players here in just a moment interviews
from the speech chess championship of
when we return
[Music]
and we are now joined by our players of
the second speech Chess Championship
match of the 2019 calendar here with us
here Maxime vache the Krav Wei Yi the
final score 21 to 10 Maxime when when
you were down five and a half one and a
half I think a lot of people would have
thought thought this final score was
crazy but how first of all how did you
hold it together
psychologically was there ever a
frustrating moment where you just knew
you weren't playing your best chess and
then what what what thoughts can you
give about how you kept your your
mindset in the right place as you
started to make a comeback I told him
from the start so like I remember I mean
when I went 2-2 it wasn't that much
undeserved but then I lost two games in
which I think at least one of them I
should have won and that was like
screaming its head on the truck then I
started undoing everything and I
realized that just where you would take
any chances
it got even in the most desperate of
positions I I actually super excite and
then I was just I mean that is it felt
for me it was the turning point it was
actually physically after Game seven
which I finally won after was a piece up
but I was like shaking with my mouth on
now to figure out to stop that past
sipping and not to stop any counter play
and finally I won this game and suddenly
I gained momentum I think I was seven or
eight you know actually and you know
once you start such a streak going
of course it's it suddenly it suddenly
feels very good and feels like
everything's together again or it seemed
like it did well you did did you feel
you could win this match coming in did
you did you feel like you had a chance
to win this maybe yeah after I won five
games in a row
when I won those games maybe I was in
the dream then I lost 10 games or eight
games okay and so what did you learn
then from this experience you you had a
big lead right you lost in the end but
what did you learn from this experience
of having a big lead in this format and
seeing it go away
[Music]
you learned that Maxine was really good
I guess maybe I missed it
psychologically did you ever did you
ever lose your confidence at some point
where you you know with that is that be
something that was hard to gather in the
format did you feel like you lost your
confidence at any point wayy I was
asking if you felt like you've lost your
you've lost your confidence at some
point yeah well we know it's hard Maxime
you haven't been playing well since I
shaved your beard but now you're playing
better you want to talk about that
actually the first two games after you
shave me well right but then I had just
ran out of gas and a they'd perfect at
first that the motor was broken I
couldn't start the engine but you know
things happen you know sometimes you
just need one so one times as you know
you start the truce and then then it all
flows so you're not blaming me for some
of your exhaustion it's not because I
shaped you
I mean I doubt you had anything to do
with that
I'm very sorry to give you the terrible
news
okay welcome back to this video do you
have any questions for our players yeah
why did MBL I mean we're sure start
rolling we even G food that's my
question of course because it stream
always goes G fo even against Magnus so
you know I just paid my respects
I bet the fans over there we're loving
it with foot stream Wei Yi but you
responded with you had some g5 of your
own you play chief for what what was
your favorite opening you played in the
end where ye what was the favorite
opening you played in the end with the
g4 idea it was fun to watch
maxime you now the recipient of two
matches where you were basically given
the victory won by way ye here obviously
he was up five and a half one and a half
and he decided out of mercy for you to
let you come back just like I was up two
games against you in giant chess and
decided I I didn't want to see a man
from France struggle how do you feel
that people are so generous to you and
let you win these matches you ever
watched our videos or giant chess videos
no I just no no no chest
what's densha submitted I Love You Man
and I appreciate you stepping in here
today but you have got to step up your
game before our next commentary session
together I got it I'm gonna help you
bring it up I'm gonna help you bring it
up to be aware of all the ways I'm
making myself look like an idiot
camera so you can so you can be a part
of making fun of me yeah exactly
no but I will give you the link it's a
game that Maxime and I have been doing
now for five years running it's been a
it's been a while right yeah playing
playing giant bullet chess outside of
the World Chess Hall of Fame it's a lot
of fun anyway but I don't really have
any other questions to say Maxime jokes
aside obviously congratulations a lot of
people look at you as one of the
favourites to potentially win this whole
thing you are the two seed overall right
there with a car Nakamura so let me ask
you early well we have you you've never
lost the speech Chess Championship match
to anybody but Hikaru right no Sasha
last year right but I think your doesn't
win the thing well I mean if you want to
prove the algorithm wrong this is your
opportunity right yeah so anyway what
are you looking you need to do this year
to win the speeches championship like I
mean is it just get rest and continue to
trust yourself or if you learned
anything through all your experience
playing in these formats that you maybe
you'll use this year think myself that
I'm able to play in like four more days
of chest after what I'm doing my
schedule until the end of the year after
the World Cup is gonna be much more
lenient well before we let you guys go
where ye last question for you if you're
invited to play next year will you play
again and I neither the junior speech's
champ chip or the main speech Chess
Championship I guess you might be older
than a junior next year but if you're
invited will you play again okay well we
love hearing that abated unless you have
any of a question for our players we
will congratulate Maxime and wish them
best fur for the next round yeah no no
more questions Congrats Thanks
thank you all right guys enjoy enjoy
your evening and day there wherever you
are in the world we know it's it's a big
one
so bye everybody all right vidit well
we've got we've got it in the books now
just me and you left here Maxine Bosh
say the grab takes a 21 to 10 this was
obviously not the way we saw this one
going given how it started right yeah it
was also interesting for me to comment
it my first time pity that last happen
are we couldn't comment it much yeah
right I mean it's fun it was fun and I'm
looking forward to the match which you
suggested the team battle I mean I'm
excited about that we have to do that
I don't know yet what the teams will be
it might be me and Aneesh versus you and
has that might be the most fair
I think anything is fine as long as fun
and as long as you're on the other side
against the nation you can talk trash
about him when he can't hear you I think
that's what everyone wants so well this
has been a blast man I don't know what
else to say besides thank you and it's
been a lot of fun I had fun too and no
problem you can call Eric and ask why he
was left yeah exactly we'll make sure
that he he pays dearly for this one but
the the event is coming to a closer
today let me remind everybody tomorrow
we have no pom neons versus Danielle Ian
Moir speech has championship action all
week we won't have video Gujarati I
assume as a host but thank you again so
much man this really was a great and
special treat that you stepped in for us
thank you all right
on behalf of everyone here at chess calm
working hard behind the scenes all of
our mods thank you so much for the work
you do both at chest comm TV and twitch
and everyone working hard the SCC rolls
on we have another person around -
Maxine Bosh a lagron Stingley Wren what
will happen tomorrow tune in at 7 a.m.
Pacific I'll see you then everybody